Three two one
Bam would live.
We got up early as a motherfucker,
ladies and gentlemen.
Not really.
It's 10:00 AM it.
Didn't we do one at like 4:00 AM before?
We didn't want that 5:00 AM for it.
Was it for,
it was a a is a England card,
right?
Was it something [inaudible] or something?
Congo and might've been,
it might've been China,
but China.
Like what time is in Africa right now?
Is it yesterday?
I think it's there.
Is it Wednesday now?
It's definitely 1960
I forgot he knocked out Whitaker.
We're looking at Wonderboy
stop and Whitaker.
That's,
yeah,
that's,
that's 70 yeah,
but that was,
Whitaker was diminished man.
Getting down to one 70 it
was a fucking battle for him.
Do you look at Wonderboy
w what he's accomplished?
It's so impressive.
All the indicators would point that
Wonderboy should win this fight,
but I don't,
I'm,
I'm on the fence man.
Well,
I think till really is a bad,
bad man.
There's no question about it.
But he did come up real
short on the way in,
which really bums me out.
Now I had heard that his
pregnant girlfriend is in,
this is what everyone's saying is in
the hospital and that she's had some
serious issues and he's been going back
and forth to the hospital and he hasn't,
we just didn't have a
chance to cut the weight.
Right.
A lot of people claim you know that.
That's exactly what the,
what the issue was.
I don't know that drama is never good.
Especially your first main card,
main event in your
hometown against Wonderboy.
There's enough pressure as it is.
Well,
the cowboy five was big pressure fight,
but he rose to the occasion was it,
was it,
cause we didn't know who he was really.
You haven't,
this is opportunity for sure,
but you're fighting a smaller guy.
It's cowboy,
you know,
so he goes forward and does work.
Now it's like,
man,
I mean there's been guys
who have blown up before,
but the hype on a till and
I'm all up on his dick,
but you know,
there's a ton of hype on it.
If you went into this one,
it's off to the races.
It is,
but he's fucking four and a half
pounds over championship weight.
That is a lot.
That's not a little,
that's a lot.
It's such an advantage to,
you know,
fighters that have missed
weight are undefeated this year.
When they feel fight,
they're undefeated.
Yeah,
it's a big advantage.
I think that was one cheating.
It is a fun if you do
it on purpose for sure.
I think what's interesting
with Wonderboy did,
he said you've got to weigh
one 88 the next day type move.
Just kills them are big boy.
Yeah.
It kills a really big boy.
Very,
very smart.
Like whatever advantage that he got from
not cutting that extra three pounds,
you know?
And now he's a three and a half pounds.
Now he's lost a little bit of it.
I guess it's,
if you're Wonderboy though,
you want to drag this into later rounds,
you know,
he's gonna come out aggressive.
You know,
he said some drama,
cutting weight and he had this cut
more weight to maintain it the day,
the day of.
So yeah,
it's all fascinating,
man.
So fascinating.
We're going to find out a lot.
The other thing is too,
the styles,
like what Wonderboy does
is a kicking distance.
Like if you watch like the
exchanges that he's at,
he moves real good at the waist,
like a snake,
like back and forth,
but he wants to keep you not
even at Moitai taking distance.
He keeps you at karate kick in distance,
far sideways at very far,
far stuff to reach.
Dan's got to close that gap and closing
that gap is when wonder boys the most
dangerous and if you see
some of his training footage,
he seems to be concentrating on
blitzing in and lent and countering and
sidestepping and countering door.
If you look at Wonderboy as history,
whenever we fight the aggressive dudes,
they get fucked up.
Yeah,
that's like that Scott,
who wants to start?
I mean you're on and that's
what till wants to do.
Yeah,
that's very interesting.
I'm telling him that if nothing in the
slight would surprise me and list down
until just goes out there and
just just no respect merchant.
That's the only thing
that would surprise me.
But if till does win strap a fucking
rocket ship that boys back cause in other
Bisping's retired UK need to face,
that's him that he's the fucking guy man.
Even if he loses,
he could still be that he's 25 years old.
Yeah,
but not to that extent.
You know like you beat Wonderboy
and knock out Wonderboy.
It's fucking,
I mean you tell him,
man,
he's a super talented striker though.
What he did to cowboy.
It wasn't just impressive.
It was like complete domination.
Demoralized,
just controlled the range.
He controlled every single aspect of
the exchange is cowboy got like one good
knee off at one point in time,
but that was in one good
right hand to the body.
I rewatched the fight the other
day just to kind of get amped up.
Impressive.
Oh my.
He obliterated them.
That's the thing too about till I think
get so much hype is a lot of guys talk
like Colby come tins,
amazing talented fighter.
There's a lot of guys talk a lot of stuff.
I'm like,
all right,
it's more of an act.
They're super talented.
When Darren till talks,
my God,
it's almost that Conor McGregor effect.
I'm like,
I booked this full,
actually believes it.
She believes it and his was ridiculous
skills and it's going to go a long ways.
Hmm.
What's your tank down?
There's be no Jujitsu in this,
Eddie.
No digits all,
I'll ain't go to the ground.
We're all I know about Darren till his,
his fight with Serone.
That's it.
This card.
Uh,
you know,
it's,
um,
it's going to be interesting.
You were in,
I don't really know who we're going to
have Gunnar Nelson on the card though.
He's going to announce it on the car.
No,
he got hurt.
But you don't have Gunnar Nelson.
Neil Magna,
which was a fun,
fun.
It's so great fight.
They were going to do Gunnar Nelson until,
but for whatever reason they
decided to go with Wonderboy.
Jason Knight.
I know,
I know about him.
Did he already fight?
[inaudible] the main card
and he's on the main card.
Beautiful.
Who is,
he is a tough fight.
Um,
um,
like,
uh,
here's a tough fight.
Very tough fight.
Oh,
Connie.
Yeah,
he's a monster.
Connie.
Yeah.
The Japanese guy.
No,
no,
no.
He's,
well,
he lives in Finland,
but uh,
what is his background?
He's a,
he's a really good wrestler who
also has wild ass strikes mouth.
Fine.
Super five for your boy.
Yeah.
Lila magnae who's Neil and magnified
now for Wonderboy though there's not,
there's not a ton of upside.
I don't know why he took it to be honest.
Why?
It's a good matchup for him.
But yeah,
it's you're,
you're in dangerous territory,
right?
You're fighting the number nine guy.
You ranked number one,
he missed his weight.
He's huge.
Like there's just,
I feel like all the pressure's
off Wonderboy right now,
especially after he missed the weight.
But I just,
if you're Wonderboy and
even if you starch till,
they're not giving you a title shot
until Woodley loses that strap.
Wonderboy is not fighting for a
title 14 two and one for wonder.
Boy.
You got to remember the only loss
was to Tyron Woodley and then two,
I'm Matt Brown.
Those two fights and
one draw with Woodley.
Crazy.
That's why couldn't you
fight with the again,
they fought.
Well that's the,
that's what he's asking.
First of all,
he's saying,
why don't I get a shot
at the interim title?
How are you giving the interim title
to Colby Covington who only beat Damien
Maia,
who's 40 years old who's
clearly past his prime.
How was,
how was that good enough to get
him a shot at the interim title?
And I talked a lot of shit.
That's it.
Yeah,
there you go basically yet.
But it goes along with the same time.
Yeah.
It goes a long way this day and age,
but at the same time with Rda,
you know,
they're not doing Colby and
he favors send them down to,
oh no,
I'm sorry.
It's in Chicago.
Chicago to fight RDA,
which is,
if you look at Colby style,
it's probably the worst matchup for him.
He's a heavy underdog,
so I'm,
I'm,
I'm hoping,
not hoping,
I think what their plan would be,
Rda wins that fights Woodley,
which is tough matchup for Woodley
and the Rda were able to beat Woodley.
Then you have Wonderboy slipping or Colby
wins and then you got mad shit talking
with him and Woodley and
it gets very interesting.
Get super intellect that fight.
It's going to fire me and Tyron Colby
has done or dog in every one of those
fights.
But Rda Woodley,
you got a barn,
burn your hands.
That's a great matchup.
Yeah,
Rda.
Woodley's very interesting because,
because as much as as they,
you know,
I love woodland.
I think his style is ridiculous.
He's gonna be tough to beat.
You know,
I think they want some bit
of turnover in their ugly.
That's what they want.
Some turnover.
What is RDA going to do with
two Woodley and mean he can't,
he's not going to ever take him down.
No.
He's the only thing he's got striking,
striking and his movements good.
And if it does go to the
ground and his kicks,
that's a tough one to beat for anybody.
Even as striking,
even RDA striking Woodley has,
I'll put you to sleep instantly.
Striking what Lee has more power.
Rda has better fundamentals,
I would say as far as
putting it more type.
Run it together.
Kids with the high speed,
the power and the explosives.
Goddamn nightmare.
It's still the favorite in the fight.
It's not going to the ground.
He wants it to.
Woodley just got through shoulder surgery.
He just got his Labor repaired,
which is not the worst shoulder
surgery and he does that mean exactly.
Stapled the Labor on
labor from now the labor.
Um,
uh,
he had some sort of a tear in it that it,
that fucked up in the Damien
Maia fight like insulin.
They stitch it back together again,
but he's gone through crazy PRP
and all kinds of other shit now.
He put up a video of him hitting mitts
and it's only been about three months
since the surgery and he's hitting me.
It's hard.
I don't know if that's
an old video though.
He's sneaky.
You know,
he put up this video,
he's a free him doe.
He might,
he might be doing and we
definitely got some injections.
He was talking about all the different
things that he's going to do as far as
their,
he came on the podcast just a few weeks
after shoulder surgery and he was moving
around normal and moving
his hands around normal.
But it really depends entirely
on how bad the s the big one is.
The bicep tendon,
when the bicep tendon gets torn
off the muscle off the bone,
and then they have to put it back in,
stapled down everywhere.
And then they have to,
it does work right now.
Now does not for pitchers if you're
a pitcher and that shit goes south.
Not yet your dignity done,
but for a fighter.
No problem.
It doesn't seem to be
a problem for fighters,
but I bet Woodley.
So you got RDA,
Colby.
So the obviously the winner that
will fight Woodley end of the year.
Will it be back into the year?
No doubt.
Yeah.
It could very well be on
the December 31st card.
You know,
that's a big one.
Huge Guide.
Uh,
you know,
I mean I think they were trying to talk
about him being on the August card in
la,
but that's not going to happen soon.
Yeah.
That's a damn good card right now.
Right.
La is who do they,
isn't it?
Who's they were willing for GSP nae
and I'll say that's not happening.
So what do you,
who do you have now in la?
Let's see,
let's pull that up.
Did they put,
do they find a opponent for a,
this is going to be at staples.
Yeah.
Well they want to do cyborg versus Nunez
not happening in a suspended is she?
Yeah.
What's your hurt?
Uh,
her hands from whooping
that ass whooping that ass.
Damn.
Oh yeah.
Tj and Cody.
Woo.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh,
a very cards.
Not,
no.
A little bit of Struggle Street right now.
Not nearly as good.
August 4th car car's not nearly
as good as it was going to be.
No,
it was going to be a barn burner.
But in Congress,
Santa,
yeah.
So far this cards is a not well,
that's a lot of time.
Not because they have some time though.
It does.
We're only in May and then there's
some great fights coming up.
Yeah.
Robert Whitaker,
UL Romero son.
Ooh,
Chicago is one of the best cards ever.
Joe's Colby Covington.
Holly Holm.
Megan Anderson.
Hey,
let this sink in.
You got cm punk verse that Jack,
I forget his name.
Jackson over Overeem.
Curtis blaze.
Claudia [inaudible] Esparza.
That's so disgusting.
And then on the card you got Rashad Evans
and my boy Joey Benevidez was pedis.
Cm punk said take a seat y'all.
That is so crazy.
Mike Jackson.
That is,
that is so crazy to me.
Oh,
and one verse one.
Does that piss you off a no.
Cause I get it cause I'm,
I'm not a fight.
If I was a fighter I'd be furious.
But now out of the game in,
in entertainment,
I get what you're doing.
Sounds a wolf tickets there.
I see.
I get what you're doing.
It's just the worst fight
of all time in UFC history,
skill wise,
spice.
These goodies about to fight.
Now,
Eric Spicy.
When do you guys know about him?
I don't know anything about them.
No.
I mean I've probably seen him.
He's a black belt in Jujitsu
is really the favorite.
He's really good.
He's a weird body.
Um,
where's he from?
Gym Somewhere on the east coast.
Big Key.
When he's in La.
He comes through my school really good.
Merck's everybody.
Really?
Yeah.
Does that,
does that cm punk Jackson
stuff bother you Joe?
Are you used to it now bothers me.
I don't like it.
I don't mind him fighting.
I think it's great that he's fighting
it and then you'll see that he's testing
himself in the UFC.
Even if they wanted to do in the UFC,
have him on the F,
you know the prelims.
Put them on fs one,
you know,
make it,
making it a um,
a fight pass thing.
I think his contract one allowed that.
I think if it's guns or pay per view,
I would assume if you're seeing Punky,
have that big of a draw.
Maybe he was,
is he still,
do you think how many people are going
to buy that paper view to watch him
fight?
I don't know.
That first one,
that first one.
You got his ass whipped so bad.
How is the WWE like raging or is it?
That's why people are actually going,
so just that raw and the raw sewage,
which Fox has now,
which in a lot of people I
don't think they realize.
Fox decided to go with the
WWE instead of the UFC.
They turned down the,
you'll see and went with Doug Dob
and now they have the raw sewage,
which gets like three something
million viewers every time they it.
It's a built in audience.
It's crazy.
I always bet on dudes were Harry backs.
Yeah,
their testosterone's usually way higher
than everyone else's and he's going
bald,
so we're two for two.
He's got some fucking gorilla back.
Look at that shit.
Some Werewolf type shit,
but not hairy legs,
which is weird.
Yeah,
very strange.
There's not weird,
that's some weird hair placement.
Unless you say as a Bush trying
to slip out of Lego blocks.
Let's get his legs.
I'll shave down.
He's got a weird body though,
right?
Yeah,
right.
It's a,
it's interesting.
He's a kid.
He's a character.
If it goes to the ground,
homeboys in trouble,
good jab.
He's got a good jab.
We'll get that pop pop,
you know,
good range.
Oh,
[inaudible]
damps too.
Or just popped him.
Where's Stuart from yet?
A white flag.
It looked like a red cross
flag as country Dune.
Fulcan England.
Yeah.
The what?
Come on Scau slide.
I'm sorry,
I forgot that it was a Braveheart.
I forgot.
Braveheart.
Haven't seen Braveheart and 10 years.
That was Scotland,
Scotland for guys.
It's totally different country.
God Damn it.
Shit.
Okay.
It's still United Kingdom that it's true.
Good point.
Yeah.
We were talking before the
podcast about how good high,
not too low.
Raj has a scouse
Liverpool accent.
It's fucking amazing.
So good.
He's so talented.
Yours was good too.
The other night becomes so,
yeah,
you didn't till it's fucking good to him.
It was good.
That was high.
Yeah.
That's channeling super legit though.
I've done everything I can to prepare
a lot of pressure on the kid.
Yeah.
Well it's crazy.
If this is all going on,
as we heard that,
while his girlfriend is pregnant and
in the hospital and she's having issues
with the baby,
I can't imagine three down.
We've been through pregnancies
but was tearing to take them down.
Oh,
you just want a healthy baby.
That's the last thing I deal with.
Fight Week.
Exactly.
Goes.
Yeah.
Ooh,
maybe not.
Maybe not the same baby
mom or a different one.
We probably don't.
I have zero idea.
Did you sync up?
Did you,
do people know where we're at now?
Do we still have that?
Do we have a,
a uh,
uh,
a lot number on the screen and Jamie,
Jamie to hooks it up on the screen
now people are watching no type move.
Jamie fucking Jamie.
It's vibrant today cause it's
game seven of the calves.
He's all nervous.
I look at him,
he's got double C's on double C's,
whatever it takes.
He's got to catch up
and pray this morning.
Tammy for Lebron James Help,
he burnt some incense and shit.
I saw that three pointer that he did.
He hit like,
I dunno,
game six or something.
The game later,
they actually have something
interesting going on.
Never concussion protocol that's getting
one of their players out so I could,
a guy got hit in the head during the
game and he can't play until it goes
through like five to 10.
Yes.
He's missing the game because he's the
fucking basket for game seven k because
Ucla Guy.
But God man,
the fuck up this coming from a fire him.
It's the league.
It's,
there's rules and it's not him.
It's not him.
It's the rules.
They do that for basketball.
Like some CTE and basketball
players that have had some problems
really ramp it like the NFL obviously,
but they get in trouble and they don't
want to be liable just like the NFL.
They get.
Makes Sense.
Crazy though.
Huh?
The,
they're the last people you'd think that
would be putting people on the bench.
Oh,
I know.
So she came seven.
So what's going on with shit ESPN
deal like when does that start?
I don't know.
So you have C's gonna be on ESPN?
Yeah.
No more fox.
No more fast done.
No,
it finishes the end of this year.
The Fox and ESPN,
we're going to split it,
right?
Yeah.
And then fuck didn't want
to pay like the premium by,
I think it's better,
I think.
I think it was a home run for
the UFC man to land at ESPN.
It's,
you know,
it's as serious as it gets
as far as major sports.
It's on one network when it,
and also with ESPN,
two of ESPN plus,
which we'll get some fight
nights and you have regular ESPN,
ESPN two with Fox.
Not that they didn't do a great job,
but it was off FXX fs to it.
Like fuck,
where is it,
where is it?
And announce on UFC fight
pass and out to here.
And it was just,
I think ESPN can learn from the mistakes
from Fox and just make it that much
better.
I think you're right about that because
there's been some times that I thought I
had my DVR set,
but then I get home and it was on fs one
I'm like mother fucker or sometimes be
like my bed or it's,
it's like my bat NASCAR's playing,
so go to FX x times.
Well fuck man.
Wears that hat or a baseball game goes
long and you've got to go to fs two.
Yes,
I to find it.
672 my,
my only concern on ESPN is because ESPN,
Aussie has the NFL has MBA.
How much,
how much focus do you even put on the UFC?
You know like we don't want to be the
side chick because they're made to the
NBA.
Nfl.
That's that.
That's their baby.
Are we the is the UFC
can be the side chick,
you know,
good point.
Don't want,
but they've been putting on
some good boxing matches.
They had the law Marchenko Django
contracted Luma Chanko they had,
they had another really good fight
on recently check on my podcast.
It's coming up.
Ooh.
Yeah.
Aside for that,
I don't know how to English is,
but we'll figure it out.
Yeah,
I'm a,
they contacted me too.
Yeah.
I think I'm going to have mine as well.
Might as well.
I've got questions.
I got a lot of questions.
Yours first
make up my mind that like,
Ooh,
I'm flock.
SPN learn from my mistakes.
Get a translator.
It's sometimes it's like you think it'd
be a good idea to have somebody out,
but if you had them on like,
Ooh,
how long could you talk to them?
I know what it'd be for the
showtime below the TV show.
So it's only six minutes segment.
Yeah.
When you've had a,
you've had cyborg gone but you've had
around with her boyfriend or boyfriend
translates so well no,
her English is pretty good.
But if there's ever
issues so like take over,
you know,
like she'll explain it
and then it's a little,
I'm going to like,
I don't know what you're talking about.
Right.
And then told her to take over,
but it works great.
Yeah,
it's hard.
You know when,
when I had a year,
well we're on,
it was the best because Joey
was translating for Yo el
and so Joe it was dre was
great.
So fucking hard gig though.
Translate and translate nightmare.
I can't shut up.
Joined do it for all the fun.
I mean Eddie,
you speak Spanish.
You know how hard it is.
I barely speak Spanish.
You speak enough to talk to people.
We keep it light.
Yeah.
Soon as we get deep,
I'm lost Iranian,
they start real flowing fast.
My grandma,
when she started,
I was the first of the grandkids
to lose Spanish and uh,
felt really shameful because of that.
But man,
it was,
it was rare.
It was really embarrassing hanging out
with my grandmother and she's going off
and I'm like,
I don't know what she's saying.
I gotta look it over to my aunts.
I'm like,
what did she just say?
Very,
very embarrassed.
It's tough when you have a translator
because you don't get in that flow.
You know,
when you're a pot,
there's,
there's a flow and you're
like kind of connecting,
going back and forth.
We're,
if there's a translator,
just the chemistry is not there.
Right.
You don't have that fun kind of flow.
No,
but the one thing that is good though,
I,
what I find is that it allows you more
time to think about what you're going to
say.
Oh,
you heard them damn stewards.
10 off.
Ooh,
spicy coming back.
But,
but sometimes when I have too much
time to think about the question,
I'm not,
you know,
I don't,
it's not as fun.
It's not as good sometimes organic.
Then I feel like,
uh,
like I worked for ESPN or something.
Like I know exactly what you talking
about and I don't want to be that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Right.
That's the hard part of like having
these conversations with people,
is it keeping them conversations and
not turning them into some corny ass
fucking interview.
The worst.
There's nothing worse,
but sometimes you have to do that if you,
if you can't,
like sometimes I feel myself was still,
she was so shit.
You got hurt.
Oh Damn.
That's it.
That Stuart was an underdog to in
this damn hit him with some bombs.
England coming and strung.
Yeah,
man.
I've watched those,
uh,
interviews.
Oh,
standard interviews now where,
you know,
there's no connection between the person
talking and the other person answering
the questions and there's so gross.
You know what I've done in this
conversation with a Ken Jong.
Yeah.
Doctor Ken,
who's amazing,
might be the guy in the world.
He's a sweetheart,
but he doesn't do a lot of it.
He's like,
podcasts,
really?
I'm like,
dude,
go and have your public set up Joe,
or something like the pockets is,
it's as big as it gets,
man.
He's like,
yeah,
Mike and I,
the example,
I gave him money.
He will say,
you went on tonight show and
you do a four minute segment.
You're going to have to,
you literally promoting whatever movie
or the standup your special coming out,
but that's all you're doing is promoting
and trying to get people to buy that.
That's not,
that's not real,
man.
That's not the real,
you know.
I mean,
we're talking like this.
If we film this,
people can be a fan of you
then buy whatever you can
be into or whenever you're
pitching.
It's a much better way to go.
There's no time limit.
There's no restrictions.
It's crazy that you never get,
there's no other place for that.
Like even Howard stern would
do interviews with people.
He would get people to say a lot of shit.
He had a agenda.
Yeah,
he had an agenda.
Howard stern had an agenda.
Typically.
Yeah.
Dirt out of your fucking yeah,
that was an agenda.
It's the agenda though.
He wouldn't,
he wasn't just having a
conversation with you.
He calls himself the dentist.
Okay,
good.
Did he fuck people's teeth?
Does he have nice to see a dentist?
We'll hope he has bad teeth.
He knocks.
He pulls people's teeth out.
It's hard for sure.
Um,
a terrible name.
Yeah.
Well it's already been taken to Josh neer.
Yeah,
I'm her mom bro.
Old School.
That's a great name.
Do the nox teeth out like
Josh near in my opinion.
He's a guy that hardcore fan.
You know who Josh neer is and Josh
neer has been around a long time.
Fans don't know him though,
so that goes dead.
Does so cool.
Still.
That's like calling
yourself hands of stolen.
If you're a boxer,
lay the fuck off.
That's Roberto Duran.
Fuck up.
I'm not saying that Josh neer is in
the same breath is Roberto Duran,
but still as a fan,
a fan
for a long time.
Yeah.
That's his nickname.
Someone had the hands of stone though.
Like sounds Lineker John Lineker.
What about,
what about a harmonic or or Sam Stout?
One of them steps stouts.
Right.
He could call,
but so did so did a homeboy in strike
was the Kim over the UFC when he had the,
they almost had like the double knockout.
He hit a homeboy with a body
shot and they got knocked out.
Oh,
what's his name?
Scott Smith.
Hands the stones.
Right.
Had to steal,
steal,
steal.
There's a lot of that.
Yeah,
there's a lot of that going around you.
Some people just go hard,
but those fucking made up nicknames
and make them up for themselves and you
can't do that,
man.
You can't give yourself a nickname.
You just can't do that.
Like imagine if you're a kid,
you went to neighborhood and
just give yourself a nickname.
He kicked the fuck out of here.
We're calling you,
man.
I'm,
I'm the dark night.
No,
you're not.
Well,
that's what I like about Brazilians.
Like they all have like silly nicknames,
like shoe face,
either our tree stump.
Yeah.
It's great fun nickname.
Hell yeah.
Calling you if you're,
if it's 2018 and you just starting
out and you call yourself to pit bull,
fuck off.
Get the fuck out here.
Some that are off limits.
Is that the most common one
that might be on people's super.
There's about seven pit
bulls and Bella tour.
There's three in UFC at least.
What is girls too?
Because look,
there are other cool dogs.
Isn't Jack Russell?
That's the coolest one.
Those who signed
hunters.
Have you ever seen that Netflix
documentary where they use Jack Russell
terrorist to get rats?
There you go.
Yo.
It's crazy to watch
hour.
No,
no,
no.
The the doc.
The all on how fucked up rats
are and how many have got you.
You ever see that dude?
It will free Jack
Russells to go after raps.
Yeah.
Jack Russells are so aggressive.
Little terriers.
It's one of the reasons why they're
so aggressive is because they're,
they're constantly chasing
after these fucking rats.
When they get them,
they tear these rats apart,
man.
I look at that damn dude.
Those are some Bushley dogs.
That's a mix.
The Jamie that this is
from the movies are,
but these are some of them.
These are all part Jack
Russell terriers in particular.
One of the reasons why they're
so small and so aggressive,
they would go into
holes and go after rats.
Dude,
look at the blood on the back.
Where the fuck are they of Michael Vick?
Video,
dark place.
But this documentary will
freak you the fuck out.
There's more rats than there
are people in New York City.
It's 30 million or 60
million rats or some shit.
[inaudible] saying they have like all
sorts of diseases that everything that can
kill you,
they have all kinds of deadly shit.
You just don't get it because most
people don't get bit by rats and they're
smart.
But we need rats though,
right.
Dot.
They eat the trash.
That's a good question.
Do not,
can't we just,
do they eat the trash can?
What?
We just can't just breathe rats and you
throw them in the dump and just have
them eat.
I don't think they look like,
I don't think they like fucking milk.
Could this have,
okay,
that's pretty heady.
Bravos get a rat reading service releases.
When the cans did you see drastic rat?
Yeah,
but now we've got to
get rid of the rat shit.
Oh fuck dude.
Pick it up.
Use it as fertilizer.
That can't be good for the dogs.
Mami Minoa boom,
boom,
boom.
Here's a fun hot minute.
When did he fight last?
He'd lost star.
Did he?
I thought he starched homeboy though.
The wrestler
who?
Oh,
nor dean to lab.
He's very good.
That guy's good.
He's a nasty he his knee Tristar.
Yeah,
he is.
He looks at the,
he looks at the guy with the roses
of mouth from Mike Tyson's punch out.
Does he?
Does he does Darren tills got
some prominent cheekbones,
Huh?
Yeah,
but that's why he got that nickname.
The gorilla.
He looks like he's got at
least 5% in the end are tall.
Do you think someone
gave him that nickname?
The gorilla?
Yeah,
I hope so too.
That bums me out when people give
themselves around and nothing worked.
I call myself the gorilla.
I hated,
I hated my nickname,
the twister so much.
I hated that shit cause I
just sounds pretty homosexual.
The twister because Higgin and John Jack
would always call me that because of
the guilty.
They called the rustlers
guilty and the twister,
and I asked her,
John and like,
how do you say the twister
and Portuguese and goes total.
Now they're like,
oh,
can you call me that?
That sounds way better.
Yeah,
call me that sexy.
They would never call me that.
I kept calling and twister and it started,
it started,
it started sounding good when I'd
compete and people would start yelling at
Twitter.
I thought,
okay,
okay.
I think I like it now.
I did get man taught her Nada torn.
I just kept thinking of the game,
the twister and the yellow
dots and the ground.
Dot.
Yeah.
You should get a tattoo
that says El Toronado.
Yes.
Fucking never stop sticking right now.
Now I'm going to call it that.
That's way better than the twister.
That's a great word.
Sounds,
sounds dangerous
this summer.
Toronado there you go.
That would be a great license plate if
you could fit all those words torn on.
Tornado,
Tornado.
It doesn't have no exact same.
There's an a different tornado.
No,
there's Torah Nado Tornado.
There's a,
there's an a in there and English
is torn aid in Spanish is tornado.
Is it?
No,
I'm just told that the aid.
What I know I though
that's what makes it dope.
But you can't,
you can't pick your nickname.
Like county called me big
brown for the longest.
I'm like,
why is it because you're
being fucking brown.
That's just what,
and then I would walk place.
People would yell up big browns.
Okay,
well fuck that stock Greg Brown.
That's a good nickname.
Kind of fun.
That's fine.
Yeah.
That's good.
The other one's name dope.
Yeah.
That's just from you.
Yeah,
that's it.
But even when you were doing taekwondo,
no one gave you a nickname.
No,
Joe.
No.
When I was a playing pool a lot,
I was Joe the comedian to GSP
with on you on the podcast.
He just did on your turning sidekick.
Holy Shit.
Talk about endorses.
Critiquing it as good for a half an
hour has gone on about his power is
incredible.
No Shit,
George.
Holy Shit.
As GSP going off on Joe Rogan because
we trained a little afterwards.
I switched my mats out.
I had those a zebra mats that are super
smooth and no Bueno to slip at all.
Dee Dee Dee on,
on throwing kit DVD.
Was it 1997 some sort of a video.
He was still,
you know people still a na John
Danaher just put out a DVD.
Well he put out a video series
that's Betty tied demand.
I bet he paid
wranglers in fucking under
Armour tops of course.
But a DVD
fanny pack game draw.
Fanny pack.
Yeah.
Great points.
Yeah I would uh,
I would do that.
George and I,
we,
we went over the front
leg side kick first,
which is like the most important part.
That attorney sidekick.
Once you get the front leg side kick down,
you understand how that works.
Then you turn and then it's basically
you're turning and then throwing the front
leg side kick.
It's just got like an extra push to it.
But most people do the front,
like psychic rom there needs to low,
it needs to low.
You lose all the power.
Crazy shit.
You think you fight if he's
going to fight at 55 yeah,
the ones that he's 100%
and he's only 185 pounds.
She has paid 55 upset and he's only
doing it once and it's going to be the
winner of Conor.
Khabib,
he started doing this.
See,
look at this.
This is what Wonderboy does.
It's,
that's weird.
That sideways stance is
hard to fuck with man.
I used to spar with this
guy named Larry Jones.
Larry Johns was this dude who was like,
he was like six foot two but his
fucking legs went all the way up to his
armpits,
man.
Cause that the guys who was standing in
front of the bag when you first walked,
by that time,
this John Lee,
John's another tall dude,
black dude,
John [inaudible] was a beast that
could easily be a Chinese dude.
Yeah,
it could be.
if you heard it,
but he was like six foot two
black as coal dad of a movie.
Did you walking by that Taiwan?
He just all bullshit,
dude.
That guy hit me so hard.
I saw him flat and a lot
of people with that too.
Um,
but anyway,
my friend Larry Jones,
I was too short,
you know,
I'm five,
eight when I would spar with him,
my legs were normal leg,
he was six,
two and I just could
not get past that front
leg side kick night man.
That frontline psychic is so hard and
they can just move around with you.
It's basically like a jab and
they can move around with you.
You know,
it's like,
and they're safe.
Yeah.
You try and get an angle
trying to get an angle on them.
There's actually a thing on hinge Zos
Instagram the other day we had a photo of
him throwing a sidekick and he was
talking about Hixon like the sidekick best
for Valley Tuto.
Um,
because you know,
you never lost your base.
Like if you throw a roundhouse kick,
you throw the kid,
you're standing around,
you reset it.
He was kind of throwing like
a front push kick sidekick.
Yup.
And he would,
out of all the Gracies,
it looked like Hixon through it with
the most power because the hoist would
throw.
But it didn't look powerful.
But,
but when you watch soccer,
Robert too,
when it was at the coliseum,
but that's a forgotten fight.
People Watch how hoist
would be on his back.
And uh,
in sac,
rob was standing over him and he was like,
purgatory.
Sakharova standing hoists,
throw side kicks off his back.
Dude Harney Dude,
better than anybody I've ever seen.
He's on his side and he was throwing some
serious side kicks off his back little
soccer and fucking up soc Robbins needs.
I've never seen anybody remember Hixon
did that to finicky when Funai got Hixon
down for knocky broke Hickson's orbital
people forget like that w that was
Hickson's greatest victory because for
Nakia was the guy that when people were
saying,
well,
he's such a good grappler,
if he went to the ground with Hixon,
he could,
he could actually hang with Hixon.
But he cracked,
hits him with a big right hand,
hurt him,
fucked up as I broke his orbital
and they went to the ground.
And as we knock you standing over
Hixson Hixson fucked his knees up.
He fucked his Nisa with
side kicks off of his back.
That's huge.
Huge.
And no one practices that shit.
No,
no practice.
Hanzo,
uh,
would practice up kicks specifically just
just in case he was in that purgatory
position where he got boom,
it worked against old leg talk.
Tara,
remember that?
That was the first upkick
versus Appkit Kale.
And I think it was either,
I think Merola Bustamonte did it to
Jerry Bolander or it was either Fabio's
years yelled at,
but Bolando or Bustamante
to Belinda up kick boom.
Took 'em out.
Bam.
You know,
love Kickstarter.
Now legal and combat Jujitsu.
Their legal,
yes,
called little shit.
How hard was that to get?
Um,
you know what an amateur MMA
upp kicks or illegal gay guard.
You know what?
I'm Sassy.
Amateur MMA UPP kicks your legal,
we added them to combat you just because
guys are getting too comfortable in
purgatory,
just standing over guys.
They didn't want to go into anybody's
guard that could kill the show.
So now with the threat,
it's really easy to deal with uptake.
So all they gotta do is just get
to their knees and start passing.
You gotta engage.
Yeah.
Just engage if all you get,
because you rarely see up kicks in Nma
rarely because they're so easy to deal
with.
But the threat of them will keep you,
I'll either away from purgatory
or get on your knees and,
and
commenced to passing.
That's what it's all about.
You about to say Musashi Gray.
Yeah.
He knocked out jocker right.
Where that triangle choke though.
You fell into a triangle.
There's been probably,
I would say see Roy McDonald door
like seven total up kicks it history,
something like that.
Adding,
we're not adding up kicks to
combat Jujitsu to increase chaos.
We're adding it to increase the ground.
Fine.
Yeah.
Just says,
don't stand over the guidance.
Let's go.
Yeah,
let's get to that.
Smart.
Super Smart.
Yeah.
I Love Combat Jujitsu.
I love the rule set.
I love what it does.
It opens up,
uh,
the,
the reality aspect.
Do you understand that you
can't just do certain things.
You're going to get
smacked in the face hard.
It keeps your Jujitsu honest.
That's it.
Don't get too crazy,
dude.
I forgot the Holly Holm
versus Megan Anderson.
Yeah,
that's a barn burner.
Oh yeah.
It's a big fight for Anderson.
Is her her first shot at
the UFC and his right away.
Holly Holm.
Is there a need because they
could give Cyborg a match.
A good,
good competition.
Ryerson.
Uriah favor.
Favor.
If there's not a woman who's
going to give her any challenge?
Uriah family,
right?
Would it be illegal for
Cyborg to find a man?
No.
It's [inaudible] movement.
What are you talking about?
You know what I'm saying?
It has nothing to do with that.
No.
May choose about sexual assault credit.
I know brother,
and I'm not saying you're a fever,
did that,
but you paint this story market.
She comes out with me too.
It just beats the shit out of the
dualism of gallons in her corner
in the secondary [inaudible] comes out
of the floor right behind the smoke.
Cm pumps five.
My main event.
Cm punk against Cyborg.
That would be great.
That's what I said.
No,
I said that before.
Shake or not,
bro.
What would she do to him?
She would knock his head off fucking,
I mean it was like a cartoon.
Just weren't you guys saying
that guys could never,
uh,
at an MMA fighter could,
would always beat a girl.
Right.
One just sent out when we're talking
about Ronda Rousey back in the day that
can,
Ronda Rousey said that he said
Ronnie can beat Mike Tyson,
Mike Tyson.
He got shit for them.
But you know,
when the flying arm bar maybe no,
you'd still a slammer the gun today.
He was like 50.
Yeah,
I did a podcast and was rough.
She would be his ass right now.
But,
um,
I think the rough as he is he doing bad,
uh,
not doing bad.
It's just,
you know,
when you,
especially as me growing up with,
with Mike Tyson,
you think they say never meet your heroes.
You know,
so it's like,
I think of him as that Mike
Tyson and my head went on.
Then when I saw him,
you know,
he had sweats on and some white
new balances and you know,
he's out of shape or fashion.
What's running new balance right away?
You're like,
is fashions off?
We'll do this on Sunday
afternoon leisure time,
like it's the middle of
the was on your podcast.
He's on his,
Larry is with your fashion.
You really give a fuck.
They sweat sweatpants,
show respect.
What is it with you in fashion
that makes no sense to them.
I would have never brought it up.
Him wearing sweatpants and
new balance and be like,
yeah,
he wants to be comfortable.
Really?
Yeah.
It's no,
I don't show your pride.
It's like I saw a,
I don't get it.
It's like I saw Bret Hart in Calgary
and I go out and they're like,
he's in the front row and I go out
there and he's in matching sweatsuit.
Tuck the bottom of thought.
Fuck Bro.
It's Saturday night,
man.
You have my show.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
He's in Canada and he's
a former pro wrestler,
right?
Yeah.
He talking about,
yeah.
Okay.
He's in Canada.
That's like a three piece suit up there.
What are you doing?
What are you doing Saturday night?
Said you're out on the town.
Can we sweat?
So they,
that's how they roll up there.
They just happy.
It's not 150 below zero.
They're very happy.
They weren't something nice
and light judge people though,
man.
Probably a nice sweat suit.
Right?
Like the McGregor matching grace,
you know,
and then the white ten one with
that fuck is wrong with that.
Looks still looks fresh.
Your fucking
dude.
I have terrible fashion.
You can't listen.
You don't though.
You Have Gi Joes,
a nice shirt yet your fanny pack,
fanny packs are back in the game.
That brought that shit.
Come on.
I want her back.
I want 10% of the credit from,
should I just post this thing on high?
Might have more than 10%
of the credit I'm being,
I'm being humble.
You're,
you're the guy who I know who's right or
die about fanny packs and then cro cop
still fucks with it,
but he's on of where and how big of
an impact he and I had to Croatia.
They don't know what time it is.
They all wear fanny packs,
you know.
Yo Dude,
I wore fanny packs back in the
90s now you're ever stopped?
Yeah.
Your first team all fanny pack.
Damn nor deep to labs going off
up and slap the shit out of him.
Yeah.
No,
he's good man.
Nor Dean's very good.
I never stopped with a fanny pack.
No,
you just ride through it even.
Yeah.
People were like to chose
fanny pack and like,
I know man,
this shit on saw the shit out of him.
I'm always out of stock.
My boy wants one bad hire.
I made.com we were at Disneyland.
Are we close to MMA and the Olympics?
Yeah.
Yeah we are.
Holy Shit.
They're working on it.
Yeah,
they're trying to imagine that.
Well it would be,
I can't imagine.
It would be amazing now with Russia,
just when all the belts are they,
what about,
we had some seconds man.
Fucking situation.
I mean Russia would be tough man.
Woe and it really depends
entirely drug testing.
But they'll figure it out.
I mean Russians when it comes,
you know,
box and combat sports.
Russia is really pretty fucking good
with Dagestan be considered Russia.
But the thing is though is what I
was putting it under the same banner.
Yeah.
But the thing is,
what would happen is if it did
become huge in the Olympics,
then people would realize like,
you know how guys like Floyd Mayweather
and also many different professional
boxers got their start as a Olympic
gold medalist and then went on to become
these huge superstars in boxing.
Loma Chanko is another good example.
When you have like a real
great amateur background,
people get super amped
up for go pro Andre Ward.
Yeah.
Anthony.
Joshua.
Yup.
You get super amped up about seeing
those guys go pro in America.
It's a little different though,
for the reason when it comes to boxing.
Yeah.
Because we talked the other can.
We used to with Mark Breland member
of those days with a Tyrrell pigs.
We used to love it.
We used to love it when a
guy was a Olympic gold metal.
Pernell Whitaker,
you know Ray Mercer?
Yeah.
Let Andre Ward though.
It's still,
you know,
and he looked in this leg lock
Giante Walter has a bronze medal.
This was Shane and he started
sad moods or boxing like toilet.
Oh Shit.
Anytime he hit them double
outside [inaudible] and MMA,
they're risky.
What such a weird position
to find yourself in.
If a guy can punch in the face and again
it goes back to your combat Jujitsu,
all Monta.
Yep.
It goes back to your combat Jujitsu.
You understand what positions are like
super dangerous cause there's positions
that guys regularly practice in Jujitsu
that will get you fucked up if a guy can
punch you in the face.
Exactly.
That's what it's all about.
Combat Jujitsu is such a good idea.
Thank you man.
And so and is going well,
right Eddie,
before he accepted,
does it,
does the UFC being acquired by ESPN
affect the fight pass in smash cars?
Are they going to continue
with the fight pass?
Oh hell yeah.
Hell are you sure?
As a matter of fact,
the president of fight pass
when that deal went through,
emailed me personally,
let me know.
He goes,
listen,
this is,
this deal has nothing to
look at this game over.
So body triangle,
each deep,
deep,
deep hat.
Can you hang in there for 40 seconds?
I don't think so.
Sign though.
He's in trouble.
He's got a,
he's got and he's tapping
into about the tap?
No,
it's on the chin.
Oh he's out.
What's broke?
His jaw.
Damn.
Yeah.
That's what they said.
Your boy problem you'd have to worry
about is now that people don't have to
subscribe to ESPN.
Plus you get the full ESPN experience.
Now they're,
you have to pay for that and fight paths.
Is that real?
That's real.
So fipass doesn't really change it or
they're not getting rid of bypass at all?
I don't like getting rid of as far
as it grows and could be an issue.
I think the fan base stays.
How does that work though?
They're gonna stream some
fights still on fight pass.
No.
Well that's,
I don't think so.
What do you mean ESPN is going
to take all that content?
Cause cause you have,
right cause now ESPN plus and ESPN
platforms can have 30 fights than ESPN is
going to have 12 paper use at least.
So we have 42 fights a year now.
So there's no,
I couldn't be wrong.
Jamie car,
if I'm wrong,
there's no fight pass card.
I don't think so.
I think he's just gonna be a database
for stuff like Eddie's old school fight
libraries and then you know,
that's what took her show.
So.
So I don't think it's going to grow.
I think it's going to continue.
It's doing and stuff like Eddie's
might grow,
but people are mean honestly
more ESPN plus packaging.
Tough sell because I love it.
I think five passes.
Awesome.
And if you want to just go old school
and watch a bunch of great old fights is
the best format on the planet earth.
If you're a hardcore fan,
if you're a hardcore fan.
But I liked the fact that
we would have the prelims,
some fights that you
couldn't see anywhere else,
but fight pass and then they would
have certain fight pass cards.
Well you wouldn't,
how many times did we watch?
Do fight companions?
Yeah,
with the entire car.
But now you can do it on these two up.
Look at that shit.
That is nothing.
I can do it on ESPN plus Joe.
Yeah,
could be.
Could be.
Plus is that okay?
Fine.
For another thing online,
it's digital.
Espn pluses,
digital APP.
Eddie,
what?
What could he same is get out of this.
What can you do to get out of this?
Eddie?
He's got appeal that arm off his neck
too late at this point,
right?
I mean,
get an answer to that spot.
A couple of things.
You got to protect your neck obviously,
and then he's got to get up to the leg
press position where he could get up on
like,
it's just doing a leg press,
pushing back that it relieves some of
the pressure and then eventually get over
to the side of the [inaudible] triangle
and try to break that shit apart.
Yeah.
You gotta break those body is a part to
move fast to prevent them from happening
in the first place.
You've got to be soon as
someone takes your back.
First thing is don't let it
get too deep and by two deep,
that means body trying,
you know,
don't let that shit happen.
What were you gonna say,
Jamie?
Uh,
the ESPN deals us only,
it says,
so that'd be for us broadcast only at
five past is still for the rest of the
world.
Hmm.
That'd be the big difference.
Globally.
They assured me,
I didn't even ask.
They just said,
dude,
don't even trip.
I don't,
here.
They sent me,
they sent me an email saying,
don't worry about it.
Uh,
we,
we're,
we're not getting rid of Ebi.
We,
we'd love you.
It's,
it's,
you know,
don't even trip.
Sure.
That's right.
Raise,
um,
did and so that means,
and so in America it's just going
to affect fight pass in the UFC.
Everyone else,
they're good to go.
But also they,
there's no really paper views outside.
Internationally.
They get it for free.
Like in Brazil,
all the,
all the stuff's free.
There's no paper use in Brazil,
right?
They're watching on global.
Yeah.
They get it all free.
It's right there.
ESPN broadcast deal that includes 10
full UFC cards or primary ESPN channels,
uh,
on primary USP ESPN channels.
ESPN,
ESPN two along with the premium prelims
for a dozen UFC paper view events,
another 25 cards.
We'll stream on ESPN plus totaling
30 full events annually between ESPN
broadcasted streaming outlets.
All full fight cards are expected
to have 12 bouts addition,
additional and shoulder UFC programs
such as Dana White's contender series,
a new all access series and pre and post
fight shows and more are also included
in the deal.
Oh,
that's interesting.
10 tough has done so cap has done tough.
Tough has done.
From my
understanding.
So did the Dana White's contender shoes
was going to kind of be the focus now?
What's the,
why would you,
I think that's good.
It's tough is a dying person,
man.
Those dudes stay in that house for
six weeks and all that crazy shit.
I don't like it.
Who you tone.
So they have,
so even with DC and steep bay who are,
you know,
light heavyweight champion of the world,
heavyweight champ of the world,
those then you get the
insight on those guys.
Even those ratings suck Dick.
It's just not going well.
It's 27 seasons deed.
It's a tired format.
Yeah.
Everyone's just over and no more,
no stars come from anymore.
No.
What's it called out?
Your series is great.
Contender series is good.
Sean O'malley came from Greg
Hardy fighting on there.
You got some.
Who is that guy that knocked out?
Thiago Alves didn't he
come from there as well?
I'm I wrong about that.
I'm not sure.
The biggest one is Sean O'malley,
but then you're going to have a homeboy.
Why am I forgetting his name?
Sorry Dude.
The guy with the,
the with the arm.
Come on,
Nick.
No,
Nick Newell is finally Fight Win Streak.
Holy Shit.
Nick knew it was going to beat the shit.
These people on the contender,
so he should not be on there.
You don't think so?
God,
no.
What'd you take you for a world title?
Again?
Just engaging,
but it's good to get him exposure.
Let people know how good it is.
I guess it depends how
many people are watching.
Contender shoes.
You got some real
potential talent out there.
I think the real thing about what's
interesting about the contender series is
now people you'd never
heard of are very good.
I mean,
how many people do we know
that are just guys in the gym?
They're like,
dude,
that guy's fucking good and
they've never bought a break.
They never fought or they've had one
amateur fight or something like that.
But you realize like when you see
them roll with like really good guys,
like Holy Shit,
this guy's like just a hair
below a worldclass level.
There's so many guys like that
because it's one of those doors.
No,
no,
no.
And that's not what I'm saying.
He has the potential to face one of
those guys in the contender series.
Let's see.
I almost think it,
it's it.
That's the opposite of
what they should be doing.
Because I found my young dude,
I'm trying to get my break in and I'm
on the contender seas and he'd give me
nick news 17 five to 17 in one,
right.
Fuck man.
Why can't I find a young guy in this
coming from guy who had three fights?
Roy Nelson,
the finale.
That's true.
I was like,
what do you want to blow up?
You gotta you gotta fight.
That's true.
It's not like they're fighting
the UFC world champion.
You know,
you gotta,
you gotta go in there and are
finding that concentration saying,
I see what you're saying.
It should be a lower crossover.
Yeah.
For someone there can be like,
dude,
I get fucking,
I draw Nick Newell.
Sean O'malley was fighting,
guys have his same,
similar blew it up just
knocking dudes out.
Now he's a stop out.
Maybe it'll be like one or two fights
and then they'll get nick in the UFC.
It should be one.
So they're familiar with and then,
yeah,
but he,
he's,
he's gonna be tough man.
If he,
if he,
if he gets into that division
can be tough to beat a lot of,
it's an inspiring story too.
I don't,
I would,
I would market the shit out with that man.
Yeah.
I think they're worried
that if he gets head kick,
which he's never been knocked
out from the head kick,
they're worried with his arm.
If you can't defend it,
he gets brutally knocked out.
Right.
How would you,
how can you put that guy on TV
where you got to realize too,
think about how much your arm weighs.
Like,
I
mean it's not an advantage by
any stretch of the imagination,
but the rest of him is bigger and heavier.
Yeah.
Like if,
if,
what is,
I mean,
how much do you think he's missing?
10 pounds.
You see?
Know how much,
how much does an average farm way,
Jamie,
that's gotta be 10 pounds?
No,
eight pounds.
Six pounds,
dude,
I think mine is about a hundred.
How might,
how seriously,
like from his guys,
the grapple,
there's a guy that grapples without a
leg and his upper body is that of like a
dude that's two AP classes
above the guys he's fighting,
what does it say,
Jamie?
Eight pounds.
What?
The whole arm.
But that's the whole arm
and I were driving weighs
about 5% of your body weight.
Okay.
But that's the whole arm.
See,
nick has the upper arm.
He had cast down to the elbow
down past the elbows is here.
So let's say his,
yeah,
it's not that big of an event.
There was a rep,
there's a wrestler,
world champion.
Connie's next.
Oh Shit.
But Jason,
I fell on some tough times.
He started off super hot
and then lost his last two.
Who did he fight?
He,
he stepped way.
Laura's law.
That's realized.
Crazy idea.
That was crazy llamas.
His world title contender.
No one wants
going to fucking monster
all across the board.
Yeah.
Did I go?
Okay.
Yeah.
Llamas you beat Shazam.
Skelly.
Pardot Lama is too.
He lost a Mowgli.
Yeah,
man,
it's tough.
He got knocked out by Lama,
so then he comes back and he lost a
Mowgli this all the time of the night.
This is a tough fight,
man.
Army mach one or my Connie might be the
toughest fight out of all three of those
more than,
Oh,
Ricardo Lamas.
He's dangerous.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
But this mock one,
armored.
Connie's a wild motherfucker.
He does a lot of crazy shit.
Llamas.
Just chills in the top six.
I mean,
he's just there.
Well,
class,
get some.
I'm going to have him on
with his dad car llamas.
I've been like leaving him
alone if he thinks I forgot.
I haven't forgot.
His Dad is like a Cuban exile.
His Dad left Cuba and his dad.
You know if Joey and here too.
No,
no,
no.
His Dad speaks perfect.
He speaks perfect English and Spanish too.
Yeah,
I know Ricardo does.
I get to talk to him.
I just didn't want to fuck
with him before his fight.
He's got a big fight.
Make Sense in Chicago?
Yeah,
that is very interesting.
We were looking at the
commercial from UIC chick,
Steve Bay versus Daniel Cormier.
Yay.
Great fight.
Ooh,
interesting.
Like tough.
What's the latest with Jon Jones?
What's going on?
Dude?
I wish I knew.
He's still,
he's still waiting to see
what exactly suspension is,
but where does he's gonna fight,
you know,
fairly soon.
I really,
I route so hard for that dude.
Me Too man.
But why?
Cause he's a beast to Badmouth.
He scan I think in,
I think in his heart he's a very good guy.
I was getting to,
yes,
I really do mean he's,
he does fucked up things
and he makes mistakes.
But I think John in his
heart is a very good guy.
I really
do.
I just think he just makes poor
choices and he's wild and you know,
and,
and one of the reasons why
we love him is that wildness.
I liked that.
He's wild.
Yeah.
I don't like that he hurts people,
but he is,
it's typically when guys act like that,
I usually ride them off
like fuck that dude.
But with him,
he's so talented.
I literally think he's the best
of all time to raise the octagon.
I want to see him back and I
think comes back at heavyweight.
I think he beats the brakes off.
Brock.
I think he's come back fight is Brock.
And then he fights for the heavyweight
title against the winter of steepy DC.
DC doesn't,
Ooh,
that would be amazing.
That's what I would do that with ESPN.
You liked this deal.
Here's two at 19
did I had the weirdest dream that um,
I was,
that I had shorts on with no underwear
and are jerked off in my car.
Oh No.
I came all over myself and I
couldn't figure out what to do.
And then I had to go and meet some
friends and I was outside the door.
And so for some reason Kyle
Kingsbury was in there,
can get good.
I liked it.
I'm like,
I'm covered with my own TJ's
and I don't have any underwear,
and I just had my shorts on like,
and then I woke up going,
what the fuck is wrong
with a wet dream though?
No,
really not.
No.
You busted in new drill
is the weirdest dream.
Never had a dream job to my car.
Which car was it though?
This is a big
car.
Was it Joe?
I don't know.
I don't know if he had a
dream or you draw a jack?
I've met June when I'm having sex.
I of course it's my bed before it's like,
wait a minute.
You had a dream?
He had sex and you actually
busted up my wet dream.
Eddie.
I had those where a myth real.
I had to figure out I was going to meet
some people and apparently didn't have
any underwear on.
I didn't have a shirt on and I had,
I was like,
I had to crack the door up and I'm like,
dude,
I got a problem.
You've got to help me up.
And then I woke up going,
what the fuck kind of thought is that.
It's coming from.
It's rare.
I remember my dreams.
It's weird.
Do you remember yours?
Just writ.
I remember my last mine last night,
I was walking around,
I was backstage at Bella [inaudible].
I was going to fight someone I
can't remember and I was like,
I'm not doing this.
I mean it was like pleading to,
I'm not going to do it.
I'm not fucking ready man.
I'm going to do that.
I don't need this.
I'm like,
are you going to go out there?
no.
That's a weird thing.
That's like one of them.
I got to go back to high
school and graduate thing.
Now we have those dreams,
tires,
all that.
You can never remember your your
locker combination for your locker.
I'm like,
how do I open this motherfucker?
My dream,
my nightmares were credits.
I was too,
too many credits shy of graduating high
school and they were making me go back
another year.
You're not.
No,
I did.
But you remember like when you,
when you were in high school there was
always that one dude that somehow or
another fucked up and had
to repeat senior year too.
So he's 18 everybody else has 17
is fucking dude is in high schools.
The jeep wrangler sad,
he's sad,
he's got losing a year of his workout for
I have this recurring nightmare that I
don't think it's a post to be a nightmare
I think is supposed to be a great dream.
But it always turns into a nightmare
because like when I used to Dj at Strip
clubs,
I had a good time.
It was always fun.
And then I dream about it.
I dream about it.
And the,
the problem is to be a strip club Dj,
you got to,
you got to know your cds and the girls
that are going up and you're matching up
the songs with the girls,
you gotta be sharp.
They all want those different songs.
Exactly.
So in my dream,
I think it's supposed to be a great train,
but I can never read the cds
and the managers get mad at me.
I'm like,
what girls on stage?
And I'm like,
I'm going.
And the only CD that I remember,
the only one is the crystal method
because that was my go to CD.
No other cds.
I'm like,
oh,
I could always pull that
one out as your default.
Yeah.
Cause you know you got to change the
song every two minutes and 45 seconds
because every song means
money for the club.
They're all getting lap dances.
So if you let a song go three and a
half before the manager get on your ass,
what the fuck?
It's three and a half minutes full.
It's very stressful.
So if there's a girl,
a gross bust about to go on stage and
15 seconds before she goes on stage,
she goes,
skip me.
I got a lap dance and we're fucked up.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
I got 15 seconds to find
a replacement and to,
to change the mood of this.
I got a plan.
So in my dream I'm having
a fucking nightmare.
I'm like,
I can't see the girl on stage
and I can't see my sister.
Yeah,
it's a total nine.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
I'm gonna get fired.
What am I going to do now?
I never figured in my dream ever do.
I realize that I make
money teaching Jujitsu.
Never.
It's always I lose my job by
what am I going to do now?
And then I wake up,
I'm like,
ah,
I teach Jujitsu.
I'm fine.
You're the one in between the tracks
by guidelines and Joan and bring you up
Dandy on stage seven.
But he never did it that way.
He didn't have the fake strip club.
Oh No,
no,
I did.
You have to have the faith.
No,
you have to have it.
You have to because if you talk regularly,
no,
it was always,
it was always my Simpsons.
Dj Strip cleaving ones.
Alright guys,
put those hands together for London.
Oh,
see that's kind of cool.
But you have to say,
you have to do that goofy
voice to cut through.
Otherwise people can't hear you.
If you just get on a mic and a strip
club and you just talk like Kelly's on
table seven over,
it won't cut through.
They won't cut through.
Well,
not only that,
like it has to have some drama to it.
Right.
You can't just go,
oh,
here's Monica.
She doesn't like doing this job,
but here show you guys.
You got to have that
check or that disease.
She's got some unfortunate
goofy's chasing off.
Hopefully should find a good guy.
I leave this job tells,
made some terrible decisions.
Checkout Table
Two is unfortunate,
but now you gotta go all out.
She's been invented 25 foster homes.
Just hook her up.
Just come on.
Jason Knight.
Tough motherfucker.
That's really the country Diaz
look at that fucking knows man.
That knows his to take it.
Some punches son.
He ran his name,
his nickname the country Diaz.
Cause he's very similarly
the Diaz brothers.
Hmm.
Minus the domestic abuse charges.
Well,
very fucking debt.
Domestic abuse thing is bomber.
Matt W we don't know the facts though.
Dewey Knicks guys sent me something.
Those friend data.
Yeah,
dating some crazy girl doesn't care.
She's actually a stalker and really good,
but he's a really good person.
I'm like,
well,
Oh fuck you.
Thanks Bro.
Yeah.
Did Jason Knight Nasty off his back?
Great glass quick.
He's an Alan Belcher student.
Alan Belcher's Jiu Jitsu
is pretty awesome for MMA.
This kid's been talking so much shit.
Americani Mr Finland,
he's about talking so much
Belcher versus freestyle Russo.
Kamar porous when he beat the shower,
one of the greatest fights
of all fucking thigh.
But everybody was scared of that.
I saw him a week later.
He had it.
Who some are in a twist into it.
I saw him a week later and
I was so impressed by it.
I scared him.
You thought he was Mike Tyson?
I was like,
Bro,
it's like Jesus Christ.
What you did was insane small at the time.
He had real smart in a twister.
He had them in the truck,
almost finished him route Somar gets out,
gets out,
has Alan Belcher,
all sorts of leg lock trouble and Al
Belter just dismantled all that shit and
beat the fuck out.
Dean lister and who else
was it Tom to blast?
No,
he brought in,
uh,
for that fight for a month.
He brought in Dean this during
Dobby Ramos who's in the UFC.
Be Ramos is really good at like locks too.
So he had,
he had dean lister,
Dobby.
Ron was on his legs for a month.
He said the first two weeks he
tapped out probably 500 times,
but then he started learning how to
stop the leg locks to the a month.
Then he went into it,
beat the shit and then he made,
he made a DVD called immunity.
How to stop black glass.
Remember that immunity Alan Belcher.
Like he's over there talking,
dude,
I'm telling you homeboy.
He's talking so much shit.
Then when they did the posts,
you know Wayne's,
when they always interview,
he was like,
I'm going to beat the shit out of him.
He was going hard in the pace.
Well,
Jason Knight is one of the few fighters
in the UFC where they can't show his
flag because this flags get
the fucking very flag on it.
Mississippi still has the
confederate flag and their state.
Yeah,
they're proud of that shit.
Jamie,
can you get the fight
on that screen as well?
That is it.
That is fucking crazy.
Which is five the night written all
over his big ass screen right here.
Sharp.
Why y'all turned my next all stiff.
What we do,
look at that right there.
Oh fuck.
Three screens in here.
This is like a God damn sports bar.
It's like we're at buffalo
wild wings minus the wings.
This is a very,
very interesting fight and 80
[inaudible] has been talking crazy shit,
huh?
Oh dude was going so hard in the paint.
He goes,
this is a long trip for you to come
just for one round to get knocked out.
She's going super hard.
Then you just trying to get them
emotional because he from England?
Yeah.
Does he live in?
No,
he lives in Finland.
We did.
At least he did for a while.
I don't know he,
they used to call him
Mister Finland I think.
I think,
yeah.
Nights.
The underdog here.
Yeah.
Well I mean he kind of has to be
after those two losses in a row,
but our mayor Connie was a guy who burst
on the scene a few years back and you
know,
was really promising but we haven't yet.
People don't talk about it much.
Oh No.
They will feel,
oh shit.
Oh,
jump on him.
that Pete Guard America.
This isn't what he wants.
You don't want to get in these scrambles
in the straight up cock fight with your
with nightmare pulled guard quit.
Tommy walked to them and
stash it to look at that.
Please don't do that.
He's controlling his biceps
and talking shit to him.
Hit.
Don't do that though.
Oh,
good posture and he did a good job at
avoiding any kind of guard attacks.
Yeah.
The way he did that by
planting down those biceps,
a very small slice of control and then
he postured up at the Mirman time broke
through those legs.
He's been doing his homework
and he's telling him that too.
Like you ain't getting shit off on me.
Let's snake tattoo hanging
over his shoulders.
Interesting.
It's like a Mandy to the main stage.
Yes.
It's very similar.
Just talking.
He got hurt.
He got hurt and get a motion.
Heard jabs or,
yeah,
touching him.
He was having a problem with that.
I did.
He has a lot of scar tissue on his face.
If you look at his face like she looks
like a great whites knows it's fucking,
it's just all sorts of
shit all over as well.
That style,
I mean that crazy bulldog style
doesn't really work these days,
man.
Once you get to upper echelon level,
it works until you,
you can't take a shot anymore because
your face just gets smashed in too much.
Then when you get,
the technicians are like,
all right,
cool man.
That's what you like.
Just engaging.
Exactly.
That's what you want to do.
Cool.
Yeah.
Guys just are smart.
He's mock.
Juan just keeps looking for that right
hook counter and he's doing it real nice.
I like what he's doing.
I like his jab to Oh,
there you go.
Yeah.
Oh,
I'm here.
Connie is a good wrestler too.
Is a very good,
yes.
That's his background.
Oh Shit.
Okay.
He just keeps more of that damn look.
Get them yet.
It's comfortable in there.
Did it.
That leg kick hurt him.
You think that inside one,
and it always hurts.
I think sucks.
Especially when you get
kicked right above the knee.
Oh,
it's a fucking terrible for feeling.
It just feels like you're hoping
your your ligament stay together.
And they do,
Dude.
How much always do every time you get hit,
they were like,
oh damn wheel kicks dude.
How about Amanda Nunez Kicks
Against Raquel Pennington.
Pentance of that first cake.
She had surgery on that.
Oh Shit.
Doodie stomped right on that knee
and folded them a little bit.
You see that he's throwing
a nice variety of kicks.
I liked that.
Well he's got to do that.
Get guys,
guys
that are fighting the day,
there's a whole bunch of them that
they don't throw really any kick still.
They're still out there and they
don't throw anything at the,
at the lions.
Loud,
crazy at the latter levels.
They kind of mix it all up cause you have,
you shouldn't make sense heavyweights
headway cause you know what you know,
you know I love Damien Maia fucking
more than any other fighter out there,
right.
I think bye bye now.
Oh Shit.
Oh Damn.
Damn God,
we should have stayed on top.
You should have stayed on top.
Still hurt.
I'm still hurt.
I'm here.
Connie is still hurt.
He got fucked up.
Oh,
shit cracked him.
Oh
no shit.
That was,
he didn't go.
He was here.
Oh Shit,
dude.
What the fuck is he doing?
But he likes fighting off his back.
He likes his recovering.
Yeah,
but look,
he's in mission control here.
This ain't bad.
I say bad at all.
It's small right there.
Just triangle his legs.
It's all he's got to do.
Oh,
Shahada.
It'd be triangle.
Those legs.
You get them in a dead orchard.
Does he know singling out that?
Yeah,
he knows it,
but what he's trying to
do is clear the neck.
That's the main thing he's trying to do.
He's going to try,
he's trying to get invisible collar at
this point or some kind of meat hook or
something with a stupid,
oh shit.
He's got them.
He's got them 10 10 seconds.
He's got 'em in Vertiv.
Oh,
he got out.
Shit.
Look at that Dark Hilton.
Go for it.
10 seconds.
You're couple shots.
Oh Shit.
Look at him.
Awesome.
You ain't talking shit anymore.
How about he started talking shit.
How about he stood up,
starts,
I can shoot
this kid.
Oh,
you went to the wrong corner down.
They bet they're
all fucked up.
That was awesome.
But again,
British based on the night
caught them with some good shots.
Hurt him badly.
Hurt him bad.
40 seconds left to
fucking go down to guard.
Like,
I don't care if you liked it.
Not a bad idea.
I'm going to triangle.
Ah Man.
If that fight was two minutes longer,
he could have caught him in something.
He was scrambling.
You got 30 seconds on top of them.
30 you know how hard it is
to get a finished 30 seconds.
It all depends on,
is it the way I like it?
Yeah.
And I get off
only a of pulling guard.
It's so suicidal.
Like people say,
why is it so hard for
Damien Maia to pull guard?
He'll sit on his butt.
People don't want to get on top of them.
Yeah,
they make a sand.
Does that,
look at that.
Look at that.
Cause that's literally
let's but a bit,
so that's probably my,
I can't win any other way.
Here we go.
Round to Emmett.
Connie got fucked up in
that first weekend night.
Did he still confident but
he's a little bit like that.
Fuck and Hammer.
Connie still make taking big deep breaths.
Dude.
He got hurt.
That
one uppercut really fucked him up.
Anyone else just ripped
my hardest fuck for night.
Yeah,
I'm at right now.
Right.
Well smirked on him.
[inaudible] he's a tough guy.
I like watching them fight,
but I also like a guy coming
back from two two fights down.
Did you lose three in a row?
It'd be,
it'd be tough.
Is Kirby in trouble man?
Okay,
well these findings,
not the one I've seen him.
How dare you dude.
One FC is putting on
some good fucking trolls.
Boys I get to but compared to the
UFC and there's Bella towards him,
he's like dot.
The problem with one fc
is just about exposure.
They've got some great Thai
fighters over there in Asia.
One FC is huge,
huge,
huge to this giant reaches
like a billion households.
Yeah.
Baskins huge star.
No,
in Asia he is.
Oh look at this talking to a
seasoned agents to now son.
Yeah,
it is.
But one fc,
I'm telling you,
Brendan,
it is very big overseas.
I know it's big.
If you're not in the UFC,
it,
it's,
if you're not in the UFC,
it's a tough goal,
man.
It is.
It's a tough go.
But,
but it's not over.
One FC is catching up.
Yeah.
In Asia.
I mean they're bigger than
Bellah tours over there.
They're Belko doesn't
really do age exactly,
but that's our number two right.
Are number two in America's Bella tour.
Well,
no,
no.
Towards getting bigger.
Right.
It's bigger.
I mean they're in Europe.
They're obviously just
had that card and one,
they're heavyweights,
uh,
tournament.
They're doing it,
they're killing it right now.
And then really ratings really
got jail fade or coming up.
You got Ryan Bader,
mitre owned.
Well they need a heavyweight champion.
Yeah.
Michael.
Then in page you see that they
don't have a heavyweight champion.
Can I have one now?
Under the year?
Yeah.
There aren't that many big guys.
It's Ryan Bader.
It could be issues,
right?
Cause he's a light heavyweight and
he's the light heavyweight champ.
But maybe fights better at at heavyweight
than he does it line everywhere.
It's true.
She felt Davis' head kicked Kale.
That was crazy.
Davis looks good.
That was nasty.
Amir Khan inside night talking shit.
Now I have some comments.
Americani got that Nice Jab,
right Hook Combo.
Yeah,
that right hand.
He throws us.
Look for that show.
We clipped him.
Damn.
He's got a good ride,
Huh?
Oh,
nice uppercut to it.
Mixed it up.
We're missing Colorado going,
God,
these guys are sweat.
Why doesn't he just hit
him with a right hand cal?
You'll be like,
why?
What is it?
You just know calen got,
keep your hands up.
Why does he throw the front kick?
Oh,
shoot him again.
Oop.
He guilt guilting coming
in hot note pads again.
Yeah.
You can't get it as well.
I grew up trying on the body and
doing a good job at defending.
You wouldn't give that first
round ten eight what'd you
Nah,
no,
no.
Maybe he ain't been down.
The rules with the number plate.
What's the new rule?
The new
a scoring system.
What is it?
It,
the new scoring system is when
you show like a clear advantage,
you'd have to have someone look at it.
But a clear advantage is the difference
between like winning and winning.
Like clearly he clearly
won that first round.
I would have to look at it like how they,
how they uh,
frame it.
Now I think we have a real problem being
imprisoned by that 10 point system.
I think the 10 point system is stupid.
Pretty much happened there.
What do you think about
the recently there's been a
bunch of early standups from
the ground while the Leon Roberts
one with a Damien Maia and uh,
uh,
[inaudible] was ridiculous with the wizard
Riddick that was super is ridiculous
that someone not knowing what's going on.
Not only that,
I mean you're dealing with a fighter
that is taking a fight on last minute
notice against a super dominant wrestler
and he essentially is in a great
position and could maybe get his
back and that just biggest advantage.
You fuck them.
I'm our county takes him down now here.
Yeah.
He felt was another fire recently
when they were on the ground.
The guy was like side controller,
the mount,
and then the ref stood them up like that.
Upon that same chili card,
there's also in the girls fight where
the female referee let them just stay on
there,
but with no engagement.
I'm like,
stand them up Nazi.
She doesn't want to be down there.
She does.
No one's interacting.
Let's go taste it nights.
He's got a fucking wicked mission control.
He pulls to that Michigan lateral.
Very nice.
Got immediately right now he
could hit a triangle right here.
Made huck look at that.
Oh
yeah.
Has he been made?
Connie ain't doing shit
on the ground either.
He's not getting it mean he
might be doing okay defensively,
but he's not getting shit off often.
No,
he's threatened nonstop down there,
which to me should be
a win for Jason Knight.
Jason,
I'd gone for a leg lock here.
I thought about it.
Amir,
Connie Austan.
He's losing and so he goes to the ground,
but over that leg lock right here.
Oh Shit.
It's like a around a piece.
Maybe he'd be
judges.
The judges for sure.
Given that the Americana,
that's it's one,
one,
one with him on the ground.
Zero.
He still,
he still took them down sucks though.
Cause Jason Knight was doing work
and threatened him the entire time.
When the gun get the gift to be a Connie,
he's on the defensive.
That's the flaws in our judging isn't,
it's a giant.
It's fucking insane.
I feel like it should be
like a hundred points system.
I feel like there should never be
any standing up five minute rounds.
There should never be any standup.
Yeah,
I'm with you.
Why you standing in lockdown and have
forever five minutes by the time they get
to the ground,
like there's not any get downs.
Like if there's boring on the feet,
they're not,
they're not that doing what you
doing guys just hold position,
you know shit.
It's just the fight.
That's just how I got the fuck out of
four minutes to get back up
to the feet when the over,
because without
this Brendan,
this is what happens if you could,
if they stand them up because they're
holding than guys w why would they learn
Jujitsu if they get taken down?
If a strike,
it gets taken out.
All you gotta do is get good at holding
and the Rep's going to stand them up.
That's what it leads to and it fucks a
sport up round three you can't have that.
That gives,
that gives a strike or a reason to not
learn Jujitsu and just hold and look to
the referee,
stand them up or fucks up the teachers.
Learn wrestling.
Keep winning by just holding him down.
One take done.
Then you got to learn how
to fight off your back.
God,
you got to learn how to fight.
You got to push the sport.
You can't go backwards.
I'm Eric standard looking for a take
down again and standing up the fight.
That takes everything backwards and it
makes it so you don't have to learn into
and trying to win the fight though.
It's an issue that you could say
the same thing about them standing.
That happens all the time standing.
No one says shit about that.
We can't put them to the ground.
Why not?
We do an in combat Jiu Jitsu.
We have get down's baby kid kid down
to minutes.
If you guys,
there's no take down in two minutes,
we get them down.
Remember when this was illegal,
these kidneys tracks were illegal.
They're not illegal anymore.
They should do more of those.
When a guy has a someone's back,
remember how hits him.
He used to do that to the stomach.
Why don't they do that?
That opens up the neck.
People forget about it and you
don't need to think about too.
Yeah,
it's true.
Totally because those are
some serious kicks in.
You're breathing,
but he does it.
They never did create some
space in America is so strong.
Wrestling mats had a flying Kung Fu here.
This guy's too greasy and he's got us.
Oh triangle.
Oh,
you had it for a second.
He's trying.
He's trying to throw some shit up there.
It is.
So receives throwing some shit up.
Kevin has in his corner.
Very.
Connie's must be,
Huh?
Yeah,
100% but of course.
But how's your boy Dan harder.
You still talk to him?
Eddie,
you in touch with him at all?
I haven't talked to him in a while,
but he seems to be doing
great as a commentator.
Yeah,
he's doing great.
He's really good at it.
He's a,
but he's got a book out too.
What does it say?
Like half reptile or something like that.
50% reptile.
I forget what it's mixed martial
arts on conspiracy theory.
That life.
It's got to go for a triangle right here
and he's got a fucking madame theories.
Part reptile part reptiles.
It's about his life story.
So UFC,
MMA in me,
part rep talk.
I feel like it's a bad name for a book.
I don't know.
Maybe he's got a personalization for it.
Lizard man.
Damn,
this is a,
this is a terrible
position for Jason Knight.
Just,
it's losing.
Honey is not doing Jack Shit.
It doesn't matter.
But Jason Wright is
threatening off of his back.
Oh,
there we go.
Jamie gets caught with the crack head.
That's actually quite New York crackhead,
right?
They're
like,
what is our mayor county going to do here?
He's trying to stack them and,
and just pressure through
and just survive here.
Look at him and shit like that.
He's not doing anything.
This is what you guys want it though.
Yeah.
I want to stand it up.
Oh.
Oh
right.
When we were talking about Mark Goddard,
how Jesus was complaining White Dude,
he's not doing shit.
He wasn't doing shit.
That is true.
Jesus Christ.
How dare you stand them up for action.
How dare you.
There's action on the ground.
Well,
I like this action.
Oh,
he's stunned him.
He's done them.
Connie,
please could take him down and while
he wants some points while he's getting
them,
I mean that's a,
that's literally always been
able to do in this fight.
Other than that,
a couple of jabs,
he landed in the first round.
True.
Beaten them.
Stand up.
Oh,
it's gone for a leg lock.
That's a tough sell.
He's got to do something.
Yeah,
a this now.
Oh Dude,
for sure.
But it's weird.
He's losing the fight.
But what the fuck is con,
uh,
I'm here.
Connie done taking them down.
But that's it.
Is that enough?
It's just being on top of it
enough when the guy on top,
but he did get the tape
that you got to take down.
But it's not good enough.
It's not.
It is in our common sport.
But how much of this should be scored
with Jason Knight controlling off of his
back and going for
submissions versus I'm here.
Connie literally here doing nothing.
Zero.
But he has can control top control.
Right.
But,
but also anybody's control though.
He's just on top.
He doesn't have any control but just doing
anything but holding him in the spot.
But Jason,
nice thought landing.
He's not,
when he's trying,
he's at least trying to be offensive
off of his back and Connie's literally
doing nothing.
Like all he's doing is holding on here.
Look,
that's what you guys wanted.
But Hey,
that's part of this
port lands a shot there.
He lands a shot that's good for him.
That's good for him.
But Jason Knight is being way more active.
Amir.
Connie thrown a few shots there.
Asked.
Yeah.
Now he passed.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm with you man.
But there was a boy,
they score it.
Look out.
Look out for Jason Nights.
Neck.
I mean,
it kind of has this fight easily.
Ooh.
He could have a 10 figure choke.
You,
you remember that?
What does that fucking that step over?
Oh Shit.
Oh,
he heard him.
He hurt him.
I'm your conduct or legal needle?
Uh,
I think it was a punch to the suspect.
I think the was to the body,
wasn't it?
Was it?
There it is.
Oh No,
mere county definitely win this fight.
I don't think he's the one he finished.
What's that?
What's that technique?
Goddamn,
I can't,
you're,
you got one arm under the,
uh,
the,
the arm,
one arm over the top and
you step over with the legs.
You know that move.
Fuck for a proven record.
That entire time I call
it a 10 figure Cho.
I forgot the proven well
isn't a 10 finger choke?
The one when it's uh,
in the chest,
you got him in the chest and you have the
head planted and we should call it the
10 finger chokes.
It proved a necktie would for whatever
reason we call it the 10 figures.
Well Tony De Sousa is the reason why
everybody calls it the Peruvian necktie
because he's got a pet who and there's
a Peruvian darts as well too when if you
oh,
there it is.
He was out out.
Huh?
I get pissed off.
Ooh,
he knocked him down twice.
Yeah,
twice.
But so is
it a 10,
eight round that first Peter to draw it
could be a draw to draw this guy from
the UK.
No,
fill out.
Oh,
he's not from the UK so hey,
maybe David.
Kevin.
Ah Nah.
I bet Jason that it
loses the fight decision.
Could be,
could be
interesting.
Dom Tom,
what do you think?
They're probably going to
give it to mirror Kami.
This his name.
I'm here.
Connie.
My probably give it down.
Yeah,
he got the take downs.
You know,
he didn't do anything on top,
but those take downs count.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Now is that the coal Maine,
do you remember?
That's fine.
Do you remember that guy?
That was more,
I think the,
the first gear teen master in Nma
was that little pecan Kenya Guy.
Do you remember him?
He used to fight and shoot
a little Brazilian guy.
His name was Antonio Nogueira.
Oh yeah.
I can,
I forget guillotine.
So many motherfuckers.
I think he was uh,
an Andrea Penna,
Doris Guy from Nova.
You young remember him?
He was a guy that if you shot in on him,
he was going to guillotine you and he
had his own special 10 finger guillotine.
He called.
I don't know exactly how he did.
You know,
everyone's got like their own little
modifications for guillotines cause you
really can't see the grip
when you got a guillotine.
The grip is actually hidden.
You really don't,
you,
it's a hard to tell what kind
of guilting you putting in.
Even with the high elbow
guillotines and Marcella,
Marcella teen,
it's,
it's hard to tell if you're holding it
like this or like this because the grip
is hidden.
Secret guillotines and the way
that pit Kango Nogueira did it,
man.
I still don't,
I still a,
I don't remember.
It's like weird little secret grip.
Did you ever get into the Pretzel Grip?
Did you,
will you a big on that,
that weird grip where the,
the,
the palm of the bottom hand is facing
outward and the palm of the topics that
towards you.
That's a great,
that's a great grip.
If you get your hands together,
But the reason why Marcello,
instead of going here,
he goes here.
That's the difference is,
is when you go here,
you need your palms to meet.
So if,
if there's a guy here,
uh,
and I'm trying to guillotine and the
first thing he's going to do is bring up
his hands like this,
right?
And he's going to defend
a guillotine like this.
So his first move is going
to be to come between your,
your hands,
right?
So if you could beat his hand,
then you're good and this is amazing.
But if you don't beat his hand,
beat his hand,
then the guillotine is lost.
But if he comes up and,
and,
and blocks it like this and I
come around the back of my hand,
he still fucked.
So it's a sense of security
split decision.
I'm here,
Connie.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Does that make sense on the grip?
Yes it does.
Um,
the also to like the same
as like with a rear naked,
it's like if you could
keep that hand flat,
it's easy to slide it up in there.
Then if you got it like this where
it's hard to get underneath the chin.
I'm not too sure about
that with the guillotine.
It's just a lot of people do
it with the Pretzel Grip here.
Yeah.
But you got to get your hands together.
Marcello Garcia variation.
It doesn't matter that your
hands are going to come up.
They think they're safe,
but we're going behind our own hand.
So that's what,
that's when Marcello was fucking
people up with that on the daily,
no one can black belts.
Well,
what the fuck is going on?
I'm defending the Guillotine
and I'm still tapping,
right.
It was the grip they
given to went decision.
I'm or Connie?
Yeah.
That's tough for a,
yeah.
What are you going to do?
Okay.
The Cub Swanson.
Zoe said yes.
Okay.
That's not a good move for him.
No Cub Swanson Zone.
Another was he calling out?
I Dunno know Jimmy Marijuana.
I'll say it's up to the Jimmy Manoa.
I know.
See crazy guys like this.
Uh,
what's the next fight?
He's talking about an old story.
What Jimmy mean?
Man.
What did the rest of the ground
amazing Arnold Alan verse.
Mads Brunel and show up the card.
Pull up the card.
Yeah,
he's probably delirious
from that upper cut.
Aljamain
he's trying to get a
fight with Dominick Cruz.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Aljamain I liked how he bounced back
from that model and Mariah's fight too.
He bounced back.
Marlin memorize.
Where's Jimmy Rivera coming up?
I think that's next week at
the mother fucking fight.
Yeah,
it is next week,
right?
Is that next week?
Thanks.
So do we need to fight night fight
companion for that mother fucker?
Or what day is that Jimmy
Rivera as a mother fucker.
He's a beast.
What Day is that?
Is that Saturday?
June 1st Friday night.
June 1st I'm in town.
You in town?
I'm in town.
That's to try and get weird son zeroes.
I mean sit and talk about it.
Oh yeah.
Fuck yeah man.
Let's do that as calen in town.
Callan's hustling right now.
Getting ready to do a special
writing or special in July.
Woo.
He's ready.
He said he's amped up best he's ever been.
That's awesome.
Your boy.
Uh Yeah.
Hopefully you get picked
up by Netflix or showtime.
Your boy Joey Diaz last night on fire.
Just plain thrower.
I was like,
he's on fire right now.
I just put Jesus Christ Joseph still
fucking around to like still like trying
new shit on stage.
He was telling me that cause Netflix,
some of the references he has,
they're like,
you can't say this,
you need to change this.
So he's messing with that.
Like how to hit the joke.
Still using that context.
What references are they?
Uh,
I don't want to give away.
Yeah.
Eddie,
you round next Friday.
The first June 1st,
which doing next Friday night,
next Friday.
I'm in San Francisco.
It sounds Tripoli.
You should cancel it.
What's happening is you're looking at
Jimmy Rivera versus Marlin Mariah's son.
That's going to be good.
That is a good fight.
Jake Ellenberger.
Ben Saunders doubled the old to Solon
added fighting to have that spot in San
Francisco.
I'd be cornering.
Ben,
you're losing a lot of standup,
man.
This is not a lot enough.
Like,
I see.
You're not like a real comedian.
Real comedians go out all the time.
Right?
I'm like,
uh,
I'm like below an open miker.
You know what I mean?
Are you enjoying it?
I love it.
The show we did a Friday
night in the belly room.
That was the most fun I've ever had.
Man.
That was so much fun.
Is it all just conspiracy theory stand up,
because I know you guys are calling
it tinfoil hat conspiracy night.
Is that just because of the podcast name?
It's,
it's um,
it's more designed to,
it's not,
you know,
there's a lot of a conspiracy
theory comedy in there,
but you know,
you know,
it's not like 100%,
but you guys do fit,
you take fan questions too,
right.
So you can go hard in the paint.
Yeah.
At the end we do a question and answer
type of like a mini podcast thing.
Yeah.
It's fun.
Friday night at the belly
room was so much fun,
man.
It was awesome.
It's such an amazing room.
That's the truth serum room.
It,
if your jokes are like fat,
if they have too much extra words in them,
if they're too fake,
if they come off Corny,
that bedroom,
just highlight,
can feel it.
I've always liked to run my,
my material in that room
before I do anything.
Joey did his short,
uh,
I've never been in that room in the,
in the ice house.
The one,
not the Ma,
the big room they did in the small,
it's almost like the bell.
The room.
Yes.
House.
That's where he did it.
That room's amazing.
That's what we just done
that a couple of times.
A Joey too.
That's a great one.
It's a great room.
When I opened for Joey,
I love it because it's
probably 90% Latin and I love,
I love telling Mexican jokes.
I got so many Mexican stories.
It's just all fun.
There's no conspiracy theories going on.
And with those crowds
crowds to like 90% Latin.
Really?
No last night was it?
No,
it seemed like it was when it's
interesting like in Ontario,
Ontario's 9% Latin,
two hours,
a lot of fun.
It's a great room until levity in Oxnard,
a lot of Lake Ontario podcast last week.
And he said that
that because of you,
you,
he said that he was telling you that
Russian mafia story and then you said you
should do it on stage.
And then he did it and it,
and it blew up at Russian mob story.
And then I remembered I go,
you know what Joe told me to
do that bleeding asshole story
problem with blood coming out of my ass.
So I told them what,
how I fixed it and he goes,
dude,
you got to do that onstage.
And I'm like,
no.
At the first my first
reaction was like fuck no,
I'm not going to talk about that on stage,
but I did it Friday and
it went over well to it.
It's a funny story man.
When you told her I was howling laughing.
That's funny.
I like you say that like,
oh you should do that bleeding asshole
story and people who are listening,
what the fuck is wrong with these?
Come on.
It's not just a matter of like how you
were telling me the story and when you
were telling me a story,
I was cracking up.
I mean I am not a comedy Snob by
any stretch of the imagination.
I like comedy.
I like things that are funny and
if it happens to be funny for x,
Y or z reason,
I don't care.
I just want,
I like to laugh.
I like funny shit.
I just,
I don't believe that like,
like there's,
there's certain subjects
that should be off limits.
It's just a matter of how
you approach the subject.
If it's a part of life,
the problem is a lot of subjects are
tainted because a lot of people do bad
comedy that's like
cheap and easy and they,
they,
they like,
they use those subjects instead of,
because the subjects are
interesting and they,
they have like a real valid point.
They use those subjects because they
know it's going to get a cheap laugh.
Like a no original thought
was the Fart joke or a cheap,
you know,
whatever kind of joke.
There's,
there's a bunch of cheap jokes,
but then there's like a
real live situation when
you have to shit your pants,
like told her you should.
Fear had a fucking hilarious joke about,
there was a bridge across,
uh,
in Sydney.
This is crazy bridge.
It's like two miles long or something.
You walk across it and he was halfway
across the bridge and you had a shit his
pants and he tell,
told the story and he had an
agent at the time and told them,
that's a shit joke.
You gotta stop doing that joke
and already looked at him.
He goes,
yeah,
we're not going to work together anymore.
It just got rid of him.
Just got rid of his agents like get the
fuck Outta here cause I that he told me
about it.
I go,
what?
I go that guy I told you to stop doing
that bit cause it was a real story.
I was with him,
we worked together in Sydney.
That's what makes it funny.
I mean but it was a real
story where he had a shit,
his pants and he was a mile
into itself and it was killing,
killing and his stupid ass agent was like,
you know that is a,
that's a shit joke.
Should into a shit show because he
doesn't get it because he hears when,
when people are talking about like why
would she send an Asian on sage and
maternity Asian,
no agent in did it's early.
Why would he,
why would he leave?
He didn't.
But when look,
here's the,
there's two stages of your career,
right?
There's a stage where other people
trying to tell you what to do.
They're like,
what do you need to do is wear a tie?
Well you need to do is change your ride.
What you need to do is go clean.
I went through all that shit too.
And then there's a stage where
they just leave you the fuck alone.
Ari is now in that leave you the fuck.
Cause he's successful
because he's successful.
When you're successful,
you can say what you want to do it.
A few years back he was
in that you might make it,
you might fall apart stage in in an
agent's eyes like agents look at you and
they go,
man,
I don't know.
Eddie might be able to make it,
but you're going to have
to change some things.
It would change the way you're dressed.
Change your hair drop.
You were eating as all star bleeding.
Asshole thing is alienating fans,
you know,
and they get it in their head that
they know how to fix your act.
They're almost always wrong.
They're almost always
wrong or he's hilarious.
Yeah,
we have the same major.
He didn't tell him either one of us.
Shit already doesn't give a fuck.
Now,
Ari is like,
does my favorite example,
he's got a flip phone,
but he's my favorite example
of a dude who got money,
got some fame and some wealth and
got some success and just said,
fuck you.
I'm doing whatever I want.
Yeah.
Bird was saying like a torn was,
uh,
he was taking some time off.
He's just,
he's going somewhere now.
Does he want a toy?
He's like,
he just needs a certain minimum
and that's all he cares about.
He hits that things out.
He made his monthly nut or his yearly nut.
He said in the first couple
of weeks of the year,
they just did a bunch
of theaters and some,
some good breaks.
No.
Alright.
Shit.
And he just,
he's got a fucking low overhead man.
He doesn't have a car.
He lives cheap.
I mean,
he's just,
he keeps that way.
It's still in New York.
Yup.
Yeah,
yeah.
He's hilarious.
He doesn't give a fuck man.
And He loves traveling.
He loves traveling.
He's material from it.
Right?
Well,
it's not just that man.
He just really enjoys going
to different cultures and be,
I mean,
he went to fucking Asia dude like Asia,
Asia standing pistils and shit staying
in places where like 18 year old
backpackers go doves like your
feeling that you're in danger.
He was not.
Not Ever,
I'm like,
what?
I'm too scared to do that.
I wouldn't want to do that.
Well,
I don't think it's dangerous.
I mean it think it's rarely dangerous,
but I think any kind of travel,
I mean,
I mean I'm talking about
traveling to a bar in,
you know,
Canoga Park could be dangerous.
You know,
you hear about it in a story.
Brendan Schaub Joe Rug and go to a bar
and Canoga Joe gets stabbed by some crazy
person.
Oh,
don't go to Canoga Park.
That's not what it is.
It's just like life is
occasionally dangerous.
You know?
I don't think those hostels are most of
those hostels or just college kids that
are just traveling abroad
and looking to see the world.
I've always been scared of hostels.
My brother stayed when
you're up until he woke up.
So in sucking on his toes.
That's scary.
Well what?
I was scared of it because
of those horror movies,
the hostel,
are we fucking terrifying.
Part two's even more sta.
Dude.
How's still is so hostile is brutal man.
How easy is it to,
to Lord,
you know those 18 year old
backpackers that are across Europe?
So I'll leave you dude.
All you gotta do is get hot chicks point
out the dude's a hot chicks would drag
him into some shit.
Put some,
put some drugs in that drinks and book
and two 50 year old and a 35 year old.
A hot chick.
But Ya,
yeah,
where are we going
to get it?
But when you're 20 when you're
21 warm hole in the wall,
I'm saying easy.
That's how they got them.
And hostile.
They just said they just sent chicks.
That's the easy chicks
work every due to fall,
right?
They'll fall right into it.
Man.
Chicks with drugs,
you know,
drink and it's over.
But I think for a lot of those people
that travel like that and live like that,
it's gotta be very hard to settle down
once you get used to just traveling.
And doing drugs and partying places and
I feel like that movie doesn't end well
for those people.
There's no like real stability.
Oh,
the meaning of life.
Everyone.
Everyone has their own
movie playing right now.
No,
it definitely doesn't end well.
I mean maybe start a pottery
business or some shit
like and pottery.
What does this one,
this is another movie that Eli Roth made.
He also made hostile.
It's called green inferno.
I did see this.
Where did they get eaten by?
Cannibals.
I like to Brazil or somewhere.
Some
don't.
This was breezy.
It was like some remote location,
like in the jungle.
I was actually a little
disappointed in this.
The trailer.
I was like,
Oh shit.
Picture of the head and
the upper left hand corner.
There's some crazy shit that happens
in the movie to send me that.
Send me that a text message,
man to watch.
Don't you think like Brazil,
like tourism is down 8000%
because of these fucking movies.
You know what I mean?
It happens though.
Shit does happen,
but you know what?
Still maybe Brazil was like slow the
fuck down with these goddamn movies,
but they do have the biggest rain
forest in the world and they do shit.
Fucking Amazon forest.
I couldn't be,
I was a text Tim Kenny and I say,
I can't believe when he's
talking about all of those Nazis.
What the fuck is is that
they flew from Germany
to fucking Argentina.
That's a true story until I text them too.
I went,
Dude,
you did the greatest promo ever for
your discovery and history channel show.
Cause I really,
I love Tim,
but I don't watch that much TV with that,
with that stuff he was talking about
those Germans that live in Argentina.
How many cities,
how many villages?
Don't know what?
Hundreds of thousands.
100,000 and you go to the village.
This is an archery term
and it's all German.
The the architecture.
We go into the house,
it's all fucking term images of a chain.
They don't speak out the
fucking lick of Spanish.
They were leader hose in that
drink and giant Stein's sure.
Proud of their history.
Yeah.
That's what's creepy.
You know what?
How about he goes,
do you know what built that land?
Juice.
Fucking the,
their,
their cavity to fillings.
Third Wedding rings.
That's what built that in.
So what I got so upset man.
And then he's talking about how uh,
the have they would torture kids.
I just to,
I stopped listening at that.
I'm out.
Well,
he was talking about how Mengele and a
lot of the SS soldiers went to Argentina
and continued a lot of their torture
experiments and that they had met some of
the people that had been
tortured by these ss guys.
Horrific,
horrific boy.
They break their bones,
bring her son back to health,
set them on fire.
Just the worst shit you can imagine
just to see like what they could do.
I went to Argentina like,
oh,
like 10 years ago.
And I swear,
I swear to God,
I've never been to a country with so many
beautiful women on believe will say no
more there.
And it's like there's,
you see like 10 at a time,
13,
they're like everywhere.
And you would think you would think
it would be easy to pick them up.
But it's super hard because they
have no faith in men because the men,
they're like,
prostitution is legal.
Yeah.
They know that there's no reason for a
guy to to get committed so they don't
trust guys.
So they're like,
just,
that was my experience that
they just like hang out.
They hang out with each other and
they just cock block each wild wiener.
They travel,
cock blocked each other,
they travel in packs everywhere.
It's incredible blessing.
They're only touching gone.
I'd love to go to Argentina.
You,
you watch this.
It's,
it's crazy man.
And [inaudible] and Tim said
you'd go there and you know,
they're,
they're like so,
so proud of their Nazi
grandfather and stuff like that.
And Tim's like,
what the fuck man,
that's crazy.
Crazy.
No,
no,
not a lick of Spanish anywhere.
And Hitler may be,
uh,
you know,
yeah,
that's,
Joe asked him,
he goes,
if you have to decide right now,
did Hitler die in that Bin on?
Like history tells you,
and this is Tim Kennedy.
He's never told a lie in his life.
He goes,
nope,
history's wrong on this one day.
And he'd be so happy about
what that history is wrong.
History is often wrong.
That's what I'm saying is
during Kennedy approves it,
it's fucking,
we going sizzler.
[inaudible] he's never
told a lie on the sizzler.
Tim Kelley's never told a line is live.
Are you sure?
Oh Dude.
Tim Kenny says,
I mean he's as American pies it gets,
yeah,
I love that guy,
man.
I cried because I thought
he's going to die one time.
I love him.
Yeah.
He doesn't have a crazy show that
where he tries to kill himself.
They tried to kill him.
Like what's the name of that show?
Uh,
what's it called?
It's like some show where someone almost
died and then jumps out of planes.
Yes,
yes.
Oh,
you a bull fighting hard
to hard to kill Tim Canada.
And that's what Steven Seagal movie,
isn't it?
Yeah,
it is terrible movie.
All those,
a fan as a kid,
but yet,
and then he also has hunting
Hitler on the history channel down.
He's a beast man.
And then he's still serving,
doing like secret missions and
killing people on the side.
His side,
chicks killing isis.
That's what he does.
What he,
he's still active special forces
going on projects and shit.
Killing people corralled.
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
Damn
Dude's another level.
Yeah.
Wait,
this main event man,
is it hard kind of bullshit,
man.
God Dog and magnifies an accident.
Well thanks for that.
So how standup gun,
it's good man.
Grinding every week.
Yeah.
Last week for this week folks
approach you for a special?
Nope.
Not yet.
Not yet,
man.
He a little ways to go.
And you've been doing
comedy now for a year?
Two years.
It's been two years.
Shit,
two years I've been doing live
fire the kids for over three years.
That's where it started.
Yeah.
Damn.
I,
for some reason I thought you
were doing standup for a year.
I've been doing it.
My first spot was at the comedy store.
I have it written my phone.
I'd have to look comedy chaos night.
Uh,
no,
it was a,
they gave me a spot in the belly room,
fastest rising comedian of all time,
right.
With zero standup experience and then
all of a sudden you do standup and now
you're fucking playing all
over the world making loot.
Right.
It's good.
You're getting paid,
right?
Yeah.
That's almost as good.
That's incredible.
I'll never fast fall time.
You could be,
generally you grind for about 10
years until you pop if you do it all,
you know.
So,
but I think you can do like the Charlie
Sheen route where if you have some sort
of falling,
you do shows and then people are like,
this sucks.
I don't come back.
I think the sign of it is that you can
come back to if you sell tickets of
places you've been before.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
So it's not,
so they know it's not a gimmick.
That's the big thing.
Yeah.
That's,
I'm doing it and which I can learn.
It's either way.
It's incredible.
Congratulations.
Thanks for the fucked.
And I didn't,
you know,
I was hanging out with Joe
in the comedy scene for many,
many years.
I seen comedians just eat shit,
you know?
Can we crash?
Yeah,
come and go.
Never make it.
Same guys from 15 years ago still
trying to make it same material.
What you're doing is incredible,
man.
It's unheard of.
Thanks man.
Sam was telling me you are killing it.
The other night I had a
good set Friday night.
It came together.
It was a,
it was the first set I did not stoned.
That's good.
So I decided,
you know what,
unless you're really good at something,
you shouldn't be smoking
weed and doing it.
You know what I mean?
And until you are super confident
and you got your shit down,
don't smoke week.
You know what I mean?
So I decided to try it out,
like not smoke weed and go on stage
and see what happens and earn.
It went good.
It went,
it went better than that
was probably my best set.
So,
and then you guys are at cobb's on Friday,
Friday at cobb's has never,
never been there a bunch with Joe.
Love Cockins day the best.
You've been there a couple of times.
Uh,
twice now.
Headline.
Yeah.
Fuck.
Twice down.
Then I'll be back.
He sell it out.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
That's a 300.
That's 400 seats.
Yeah.
God Damn Dude.
Holy Shit.
Then we do a Saturday,
we do Sacramento,
the punchline.
So that's a smaller,
that's like I think 150 to
hundred or something like that.
Uh,
but uh,
yeah.
Can San Fran to,
until I get my shit together,
you know,
I'm going to go on stage,
uh,
clear-eyed or this the smartest route man.
And then later,
once I,
once I feel super
confident in my material,
um,
and
my problem is I have way too much material
and it's just scattered everywhere.
All these ideas,
every day I have new ideas,
but they need to be organized
more and fleshed out.
And that's what I did for this show too.
I decided,
you know what,
there's just so much
and it's overwhelming.
I just took three pieces,
pull my goal.
I'm just going to stick to these three.
Yeah,
exactly,
exactly.
And,
um,
I've served as great at
helping with that too.
At first I was writing
everything out and then I,
then Joe,
he told me,
he goes,
dude,
you're,
you're at your best when you don't write
it out and you just go off the cuff.
So Joe,
he told me,
just have ideas but don't write anything
out and just go out there and try it.
And I,
and I did that and I
think that's for me that,
you know,
Friday I just had powerpoints
and a couple of lines like okay,
this line is kind of funny in
that line is kind of funny.
And then I just went off and
just kind of just went for it.
It worked out great.
It worked out.
Samsung,
I just doing the ice
house last night was him.
He said it good.
Oh cool.
Cool.
You guys write your material out,
material out.
Well,
you know what,
because hanging out with you for
fucking 20 years in the comedy clubs,
you,
we stress,
you got to write shit out,
you got to write shit.
You tell every company,
right?
Yah.
So that's what I was doing.
I was writing everything out and a Joe,
he told me,
he goes right now,
maybe you shouldn't write shit out.
Just go out there and just free ball,
just have some ideas.
And I said,
are you sure?
And he said yeah.
So I did a couple of
spots with them at that,
uh,
Ontario Improv.
And those are,
those are two of the best
shows I've done with Joey.
So I decided to do that.
Just have instead of write everything out,
maybe write out the funny,
you know what I mean,
but just kind of go out there and then
repeating the same set over doing new
sets of written every sets mixed up.
Different
bullet points or like what's like say
if you had a bid on building a table,
whatever.
Like it's the bullet points,
the funny parts.
You have memorized the line,
like memorize the fund and
then the way you set it up,
you're going to have to Kinda,
I kinda just go for it
cause it's more natural.
Exactly.
Cause if you start memorizing shit,
um,
it takes away from the spontaneity.
Yeah.
It just doesn't,
it's not funny.
You can find it in there though.
The spontaneity.
Even though you have a
structure you get to play with.
The one thing,
the one thing that I've
learned for me anyways,
like I watch,
I still watch Chapelle over and over
and just like you know it for me,
like the latest Chappelle when he tells
a story and he's telling you like a 10
minute story of how shit went down.
To me that's the funniest.
She had an actual real
event like the mafia story,
the Russian mafia story
with Bert Kreischer,
right.
It's an actual story,
Then you see how real it
is when he's describing it.
Instead of trying to make up a
joke and trying to find funny,
stick to funny stories and then that'll,
and then from there you could kind of,
you don't know,
you know Joe shooting mine on Monday
night in Vegas and the shooting six of
them,
not just six.
So there's six comics,
30 minute specials,
but big j auctions in that.
Who's hilarious?
Christina P.
Thompson Barrows wives is in that.
She's doing that because she
just didn't know Sherry has this.
I wonder why just below
one they'll fuck up.
I know,
but why not just shave and do an
hour trying to extra bloat that bank,
I love her at that extra blow up.
But with Joe.
Yeah,
Joey's,
yeah.
And then they shoot to 30 minutes for him.
He shoots on Monday night in Vegas,
Sun Room in Vegas.
But when you do those 30 minutes,
cause I,
you know,
I'm used to dealing with you and I'm like,
oh.
And you're like,
I'm gonna shoot it here.
This is what's happening.
And there's,
you know,
you have say in marketing with that,
it's different that can
shoot in here selling.
He's going to be,
this is where the time different animal,
it's a different animal for sure.
Brendan selling out COBB's
in San Francisco by himself.
Holy Shit.
That's fucking huge man.
So that consumer in Boston,
the what?
The Wilbur Theater and house
and it's 1100 somethings.
Shit.
God Damn.
I told him that he's,
he's probably one of the fastest rising
comics coming from never doing standup.
I mean who else is there really ever,
ever.
Right low ever.
For sure.
That's what I'm telling stand up to
selling out theaters in two years.
Did you know this crazy?
I mean,
it's incredible.
It's incredible.
Doing like fucking an
hour and killing like you,
you put in the work,
dude.
That's what I tell other young comics.
I say pay attention to him because this
is what happens when a person takes pro
athlete type of discipline
and applies it to stand.
That discipline is everything
that work ethic and discipline,
that's everything mad.
It changes the whole game because
a lot of comics are funny,
but they're fucking lazy.
They're fucking lazy and they don't they,
that's why I like you.
You're dealing with guys who do the same
material year after year after year and
they never do specials.
There's a bunch of those guys that are
really talented guys and they just never,
they never bothered to record anything
cause they don't want to have to,
right.
They don't have to rewrite.
It doesn't make sense to me like it.
We talk about work ethic
and stuff like that.
I see these other comedians
who maybe aren't doing it,
but like,
don't you see the guys like Rogan and
burn deleah like you want to be on there?
You want to do what they do,
right?
Oh,
he's got a guillotine.
Fuck Nasty.
It's the same with fighting.
Just like you look at GSP,
it's like he's doing this and this.
Don't you want to be like that?
She'll probably follow that plant.
But people got scared.
But here's the thing,
you get scared and then
he finally get some tools,
right?
Like say if you have an act like
you put together an act and you're,
you're like,
before we ready to film a special,
the idea is that your act is killing,
right?
So if your act as killing,
you've got molden at home.
He didn't want to let that go.
Like I got to let it go.
Oh,
let's look at this.
I can't wait.
Decide,
go.
I gotta
take it aside.
But if you don't do that,
you don't keep getting better.
But here's the thing.
One thing that I've learned,
even though there was a lot of fear
and letting go of that old material,
you always write new,
better material because
you're a better comedian now.
You understand comedy better.
Yes.
You just going to do better.
Like for me,
like letting go that like
Bruce Jenner bit God,
it was so hard to let go.
I didn't want to let that one
go because of the special.
Yeah,
no,
but I couldn't,
I couldn't do that if my life
depended on it right now.
I don't know how it works.
I don't know the beats and
I wouldn't do it right.
But when you get to a point when you
get a bit so tight and so finally tuned,
that's when you got to let it go
and then you move onto the next one.
And I've got some shit now that that's
killing harder than that bit did.
But when I first started doing,
you know,
a year ago,
year plus ago when I first released that
Netflix special and then I went right
into write new material and doing
new material is on shaky legs mat.
And a lot of people don't
like that shaky legs feeling.
You get real scared,
but you got to go through that.
You've got to go through that.
And that's what makes you grow
and continue to get better.
But you know,
one of the things that helps me a lot
that a Jeremiah Watkins show that stand up
on the spot,
dude that is a fucking farm for material.
So much fun because people yell
like someone look at you and go
of of hurricanes and you're like,
man,
hurricanes.
And then you start talking chin.
Every now and then they'll say something.
It is,
and the crowd,
the crowd knows like,
you know,
you just riff and they're not looking,
they know you're not shooting special.
So everyone's pretty loosey Goosey
and they'll yell like strippers.
I'm like that about them
and have fun with it.
Yeah,
it's amazing dude.
It's an amazing resource to have
those shows where someone just yelled,
he used to call it Thunderpussy.
They used to do it in the,
uh,
the ice house to the sun.
It was,
he's a great name for it.
So intense.
Just so stand up on the spot.
But uh,
yeah,
I've been doing that show for years.
That's helping me a lot.
It's a lot of bands and I told Jeremiah,
you were telling me how you get bits
from it and it's the same thing with
fighting.
Like if,
if we had train him,
you know how this is,
well if you guys know this,
there's one guy who's fucking these
really good and you know maybe tapped out
last time.
You Kinda,
you don't mean to avoid him because he
was going to be the top of this round.
I'll just go over here.
That's how I was with
Jeremiah on stamp on the spot.
I was like,
man,
I know my stuff.
I write all my stuff,
I know what I want to do here
and I can have fun with that.
But on the spot,
I dunno,
man kept canceling on him.
He texted me like this week I'm like,
yeah,
for sure.
Then the next day like dude,
I'm swamped,
them swap
and then I told him,
hey,
next time you asked me to do it,
no,
I'm lying to you.
I need to do this cause I'm scared of it.
What's the show called?
Stand up on the spot.
Jeremiah Watkins belly around.
I think there's a show that night.
Every Tuesday night.
Tuesday night.
Stand up on the spot.
Yeah.
Not every Tuesday night.
No,
not went to Sunday.
Yeah,
that's why I'm saying I
think it's this Tuesday.
How try that am I?
Am I going crazy?
I thought he said,
cause I,
I was trying to do three spots
in the night and I go,
hey,
you have to send him a spontaneous no,
cause I went laugh factory comedy
stores trying to get another spot.
I don't think it's until June.
Honestly.
I think he just did it and I was out
of town and I was on his last one.
When was that?
How long ago?
Two weeks ago.
Yeah.
So the next one would be like two weeks.
All right,
that sounds like fun.
Oh it's the best.
June 12th June 12th there you go.
Tuesday,
June 12th
I fucking love it man.
It's,
it's really fun.
And it's always packed too.
Yeah,
it's packed.
And again,
the crowd knows what's going on
for a while after your shows,
he would do like question and
answer and there was nothing,
there was nothing.
Anybody could have yelled out that
you couldn't tie into some pass bit.
You know what I mean?
You had,
there wasn't anything.
Yeah,
it's better though.
The stand up on the spot thing is better
because it's not that it's not past
bits,
it's all just can't do material.
No.
They tell you no,
no material.
It's gotta be why people have done
it and done their act two and Pete,
the crowd gets mad.
They know,
they know what's up cause you,
you know,
it's not,
you can't tell what's off
the top and once that,
yeah.
Yeah.
Do you remember we did fan Qa at
Wilbert so I did my show and then we'll,
you know,
Boston,
it was late and you know,
the dudes were drunk.
Heckler
fucking went nuclear on the guy.
I was like,
it's typically isn't how my favorite
questions go and fucking get a scarf on.
All right,
well that's it for big questions.
Where'd it go?
Fuck face.
Well,
he was just,
just trying so hard to get attention.
I've witnessed many,
many people getting torched by Joe once.
It's,
it's,
it's awesome.
It's awesome watching Joe because Joe,
he doesn't want to
release until the guide.
It's clear 100% and he deserves it.
So a guy will yell and he's like,
calm down everything and he's like,
and like inside like keep going.
So I could just,
I don't know.
I just want to feel guilty.
So when Joe Decides to go off,
it's over son.
There's no way I don't with the mic.
Forget it Joe.
Without a Mike,
you're still fucked dude.
I saw dank to go hard on these
two girls in the front row when,
uh,
when I was at the comm
store last Tuesday night.
Oh my God,
they wouldn't quit talking.
And he's like,
honey,
you're trying to get through a story.
And he was a longer story.
You could tell he's doing new material.
He's trying to get through it.
They kept interrupting.
He's like,
I can go in on you if you want.
Say another thing.
And she's goes,
another thing goes,
do you want to do this?
And then just fucking cuckoo.
Cuckoo,
cuckoo.
I mean it was just brutal,
man.
It makes a show though,
cause he did about 20 minutes of it.
There's a lot of fucking heckling
in at the comedy store lately.
What do people want to
become a part of the show?
That's a terrible idea.
There should be a warning warning.
Oh there's two girls in the front row
the other night just drunk and sloppy and
talking really loud.
You know like you're
onstage and you hear them.
He tried to ignore them,
but then you see the
rest of the crowd going like this.
That's when you have to acknowledge it.
You have to see people
turning towards him.
You're like,
all right,
I got to play cop here most of the time.
The stores on top of that big time,
which is a new thing in the old days.
Yeah.
The way I got good at
heckling at hecklers,
one of the big ways is that there
was no crowd control at the store.
I mean Zero Mad Max because in the
old days when I used to go there,
the fucking comedians
were all doormen and,
and uh,
security,
everything that was all comedians.
It's not that anymore.
Now they have like legit security,
like big guys.
They take care of everything
people have earpieces on.
They're in control of everything.
When the store picked up the
business like about three years ago,
when it really took off three,
four years ago,
that's when they'd go,
okay look,
this place is sold out
every fucking night.
And then a guy got murdered there.
There was a murder on the front porch.
Yeah.
Guy got shot to death on the front porch.
It was some gang related type thing.
Some guy did something to somebody and
apparently that dude who got killed,
he had some really dark
shit on his Facebook to like
pictures of people tied up
and shit.
And uh,
they murdered him.
He shot him right in the front porch.
And from then on they put like a super
intense security system there and cameras
everywhere.
Hired real security everywhere
and ramped up the place.
Stop letting people walk
into the parking lot.
That was a big one too because people
would just stroll into the parking lot and
these drunk people would be backing up
their cars and people would be getting
hit by people's cars.
A shit show.
What is it?
Shit.
Do you think's going to happen to the
comedy store now that Mitsis passed away?
Do you think that DePaul is that
the business is better than ever?
The thing about it is it's sold out every
night and it's making a lot of money.
Like if you go to the comedy
store on a Tuesday night,
you're going to have a sold out main room.
400 people sold out.
Oh our hundred and 70 people
sold out belly room 80 people.
I mean that is big money,
but every night to two shows a night off,
it doesn't say two,
two main room shows every night are both
sold out now thousands and thousands of
people funneling into that place.
As far as like from the beginning of
the shows that started at eight o'clock
till two o'clock in the morning.
People are buying drinks is it's make
money is enough money to keep it running.
Yes.
It's very profitable.
It making more money now than
in the history of the club.
Never made more money ever.
So it's a viable,
I mean it's crazy.
It's all within the last
three and a half years.
Three and a half since you've been back.
Yeah.
It all just went boom.
It took off.
This podcast blew it up.
Yup.
Single handed the you come and
part of it and they don't deny it.
I talked to management there.
They don't deny it.
I asked him like,
what?
What?
You know,
what do you,
what do you think's the cause of this?
Boom?
He said Joe Rogan.
They'll say Joe rogue.
Huge part of it.
And then you have all the
comics coming through.
It's the golden age of comedy,
right?
Yeah.
It's also the talent there.
There's so much talent there.
It's crazy how good those shows are.
I mean you look at the lineup sometime,
you're like,
what the fuck did I have?
I ran over cause Patanol
Oswald's doing again.
I've ran
over to see him cause he was the,
he's there for the whole week and
usually he's a New York comic.
He's just up at the or
when we can Tom PAP,
honestly in New York comic.
What do you mean?
Yeah,
no,
I know,
but he was in New York for a
while when he was doing stuff,
starting to stand up.
I only saw him post them
out in New York as it got.
I can't wait for him to come back
and started doing it again and again.
Yeah,
I saw them doing spots in New York a lot.
Interesting.
Yeah.
That's on back here.
He's a good guy,
man.
Yeah.
When Tom Papa Patton Oswald,
then Brogan,
then delete,
I mean nuts.
Top top five guys at the comedy store.
I know that are regulars
with Joey for sure.
Um,
birds there all the time.
Delay is there all the time.
Theo Vaughn is a motherfucking monster.
He's there all the time.
Uh,
who else?
Who else would you go with?
Uh,
Hinchcliffe spin.
Santina was a monster.
Santina was on monster monster.
Christina is a monster.
A crusher.
Bert Kreischer the time,
man.
This is so many.
There's so many.
Yeah,
there's salt.
Tom Pop out.
There's so many.
Um,
Neil Brennan,
they're there.
It's a fucking,
it's a crazy place right now.
It's crazy.
Insane.
Bobby Lee.
I mean,
it's just killer after killer.
I was walking by the Eliza Slessinger,
Whitney Cummings walking by the,
or the,
or the other night and it was
just roars coming out of there.
And I was like,
this place is nuts.
And then you go down the hallway and
this rowers coming out of the main room.
You grew up stairs.
Right?
That's crazy.
The greatest time ever for stand up.
Greatest time ever.
You go in there and you just
feel it man in the walls.
I don't know what it is.
And then you go over to the laugh
factory and it's like an antique shop.
That's what Theo von says.
When you feel like in an antique shop,
Oh my God.
You can't say.
Yeah,
you can do that.
When they started filming people,
everybody was like,
what?
They started filming.
People just put it up on Youtube.
They say they're not doing it anymore,
but everybody just lost
all faith in that place.
They're like,
yeah,
I still do spots.
Got Do spots where I can,
but they're not releasing my shit.
The fact that they would do that,
it's like you guys are fucking mind man.
And then offering people half
of the revenue for you to,
yeah,
just put it up myself.
It just,
it's what age are you living in?
And then when confronted,
they're like,
well,
Tiffany hydros was making so much
money now and it's all because of this.
Oh yeah,
that's delusional.
I don't know what he did.
The guy who owns it,
I don't know why he did like letting those
kids do that and put those things up.
But people that had no idea about
the standup comedy business,
I didn't basically interns just filming
people's sets and putting all their
material online.
But the way it works is,
you know,
it's a close community.
So if Joe or whoever San te Santana goes,
hey they're filming,
don't do it there anymore.
And it,
I mean it just don't,
everyone has those towns,
they go there.
They mean you'll,
you'll have three sold out shows,
not even a half a mile
away at the comedy store.
And then these they're canceling
show cause there was no one there,
but that's a lot.
But then the Improv,
the improv still doing the
Improv is doing better.
Yeah.
And you know,
the Improv moved that stupid
fucking piano off the stage.
They put a platform on the side and push
the pan over to the piano would fuck up
the whole show for anybody that
was on the right side of the stage.
They can't see the in the
ice house still bumping.
Right.
Pumping.
Yeah.
Especially when good comics are there.
You know,
with the ice house,
it's all about the have to have good
people to get out to Pasadena because the
ice house,
they've had sketchy lineups in the past.
Like you know,
they'll have Joey and Brenda,
they'll have like real
shows that are really funny.
But to also have like some
old shit and they had a,
for years they had some bullshit
which kills you because you get,
if you get known as that,
where it's like the
gimmicky bullshit guys,
people are gonna be go on a Friday night,
let's just go see who's
playing at the ice house.
Yeah.
Like fuck that man.
People will go down there and they'll,
they'll expect to see like a Joey Diaz
show and then some whack ass fucking road
guy who does and cruise ships more
for the people that live in that area.
Like,
I mean isn't it like
a local kind of thing?
Yeah,
but it's still,
if it's a bad show,
it's a bad show.
They don't want to come back.
See if it's a good show.
Like they know when I do,
I do those Wednesday nights,
once a month there and they
know if you go down there,
I'm going to have killers on that show.
You decide who goes on?
Yeah,
it's on my show.
It's your show.
Yeah,
Wednesday nights.
I do one Thursday night at the comedy
store every month and I do one Wednesday
night at the,
uh,
at the ice house.
Is it called Joe and friends?
Yeah,
Joe Rogan and friends.
And the next one at the comedy
store is June 21st June 21st yeah.
And just in the green room where
like last time it was Tony Feo,
you meet just hanging out back
and of like the best time.
It's fucking been out to two in
the morning and we just laugh.
It's the best man.
Those guys made me laugh so hard.
All you guys,
well it's just,
it's,
it's hard to find groups of
people that are just savages,
just loose and fun and ridiculous.
And then there,
this is the world they live in.
They live in this comedy worlds that
traveling around a lot fucking around,
having a good time,
talk that shit and one person to
say something that it's just like,
it was like,
yeah,
it's fucking on.
So that's fun,
man.
Fun Times.
Everyone's baked.
It's just fun.
It's just like high school
with your good friends.
Like when you walk into like
first period and all your boys,
like we hit the front.
That's what it feels like.
What a lot of ways,
right?
Because one of the things
that happens as you get older,
as you lose all the fun cause you have,
you have responsibilities,
you have a job you hate and you gotta
get up in the morning and you're always
tired.
And this is the,
the world that most people live in.
When you could find a place where it's
all basically people that avoided that
rat race and figured out some
sneaky way through the system.
And that sneaky way is talking shit
to no,
no sound check needed.
You know,
you just get on stage and it's uh,
you know,
especially when high
level comedians go up,
like yourself,
like you're going to get an hour of just
laughs just over and over again.
It's way better than a funny movie.
Yeah.
But if,
if you're a new comic,
you can,
I'm getting education to go in and get
something around with those people.
I ain't go listen to a
deal vanti about something.
And me and Joe Talk Business
and I'll go watch Patton Oswald,
do his set,
and then I'll watch Joey Diaz
and then bill burrs coming in.
And for me,
as long as I've been doing comedy,
I still love it.
I still love watching it.
If someone's Kellen,
I still love it,
you know?
I love it.
It's the,
it's just,
it's a great form of entertainment
and I think it's necessary to,
because people get so serious
about certain subjects.
If someone could just come along
and mock it and laugh at it so hard,
and then you realize like,
oh,
this is fucking ridiculous.
This is ridiculous.
Yeah.
Alleviates pressure.
What was fascinating to me the other
night with Tom Papa a Oswald and Tony
Hinchcliffe,
they all had the same
premises on their joke,
but everything was,
each opinion was so different.
I was laughing so hard,
man.
But you just see how
everyone is different,
but it's the popular subject.
So like Trump,
no sexual assault.
It was so funny,
man.
I like Joey's.
Ah,
I don't want to give away.
He's got a great back bid on that,
Neil Magni.
It's tough to take down,
Huh?
Very death,
right?
Very wirey long.
And who's this gentleman?
And he's fighting James James White.
Do you know anything
about Craig Craig White?
It was supposed to be a,
Oh,
why am I drawing a blank?
What's homeboys Gunnar
Nelson and Jesus Christ.
What happened at gunner?
He got injured.
I'm not sure,
but I was going to be a hell of a fight.
Yo Man.
Neil Neil's beat some tough
guys speak Delvin Kelvin Gaslin.
Yeah.
Beat Kelvin.
And he's almost taking Johnny Hendricks.
He beat Hector Lombard
injury that required surgery.
Hector Lombard,
Kelvin Gasland,
Johny Hendricks and Johnny Hendricks.
Correct.
It's pretty tough.
But then whenever he finds,
when,
whenever we fight,
the Jitsu guys screwed.
It's his Achilles heel
because they take him down.
Merch umum his Jujitsu is not that good.
His defense has just,
you know,
but when I say it's as a kid and seal,
the only,
the,
the very tip of the spear of black belts,
fuck them up.
That's why I was so impressed with
a Dosantos dos Anjos smashed Neal.
He leg kicked him,
dragged him to the ground and
choke the fuck out of Damien.
Maia did that.
That other homeboy got
a inverted triangle.
The Bald Guy,
I forget his name.
Who is ridiculous at Jiu
Jitsu Brazilian bald guy.
Bald guys.
All Brazilian and vertical.
All Brazilian.
Tiago Alvarez.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
that guy is really good.
You put that gas
and then Damien Maia was like,
you do what?
And he's got he,
he triangled someone from the mount
years ago and I'll never forget he forgot
his name because that,
yeah,
he's a beast man.
He set it up beautifully.
He's got a crazy tricep too.
He's like missing a tricep.
Like you look at one of his arms
like is tricep was nonexistent.
It must've broke off and slid over.
Yeah,
it must've tour.
a fruit roll up.
Yeah.
He never got it fixed cause he's got a,
a Bicep,
but then there's nothing behind it.
It's very weird looking
at one of his arms he do,
if he's still fighting,
just got killed by somebody.
Somebody good.
Pull up a surger Mariah.
Hmm.
Yeah.
He was the first guy to
tap crone as a black belt.
It was like a wonder that Magni
and amount magni in the mouth.
Yes,
he has left.
Bought.
TRICEP is missing.
It's even weirder when you see it.
Uh,
like hanging low.
Pretty weird there.
Pull up his,
uh,
his record.
This shit does.
Mangling the Mac is going
for an arm triangle here.
Well,
immediately.
Oh Shit.
He's going to stand up.
Let me see.
Is there we go.
No,
no,
no.
It's just go,
go to his record though.
Yeah,
that's right here.
Where's it?
Scroll down.
No,
no.
His accident here fights
10 means [inaudible].
Kiyota Oh yeah.
It's only k.
Oh really?
Yeah.
This one has a lot of decisions,
man.
MMM.
Super disappointed in that standup.
Matt Serra was going
off about his laundry,
about us,
the referee standing them,
separating them.
When a Damien Maia had
his bag was ridiculous.
It was really God who is the rough,
I want to say it was Leon Roberts,
wasn't it?
Yeah,
I think so.
It was a terrible decision.
Yeah.
They're getting too
crazy with the standups.
Too crazy with it.
They,
they,
they need a,
they need to relax.
Well,
especially in that situation,
you've got a guy who's a strangulation
expert that finally gets to clench on a
world class wrestler,
especially in those early,
in the first round,
early in the first round.
Got a real good position and I'm,
and you also have to think,
Maya took this fight was zero great camp.
Oh Shit.
And He,
Neil,
Neil's whooping and death.
He's hurt.
Come on.
You know we need him right in the face.
Yeah.
Did because it was legal for sure.
Illegal.
Oh,
he's,
oh,
he's out.
Neil.
Neil Magnus round.
Baby big.
He'll magni.
No.
Magni stopping motherfuckers
powerful back on Neil.
Yeah,
he's a long dude.
Huh?
That's about as long as it
gets from one seventh grade.
Cardio Long.
Yeah.
And good fight Iq.
You know,
whatever.
I'll never blows his wad.
He's always in there like,
look at that.
Just finished the guys
barely breathing heavy.
Be seriously man.
That dude is in fucking shake.
He's always been that way,
man.
Is that just a discipline thing?
Just always trained military guy.
Yeah.
Also a Denver thing,
right?
Oh,
isn't that high?
I was in Chicago at the same
fucking cardio because I was,
I was one of the coaches on the ultimate
fighter 14 he came off that season.
Even then they're like,
dude,
look at the cardio on Neal.
What does he do for Cardio?
You know him well,
but he just training nonstop.
Nate mark heart when he first
came in Denver and he just kept,
you know,
Nate train nonstop,
so he just kind of took on that role.
He just trades now.
Retired.
Yes,
it's done.
That's good.
Just doing the Lord's work now.
Oh,
what kind of work is that?
I had whatever the Lord wants him to do.
Wasn't worth saying.
I think a sell bibles.
I don't know what they do.
I don't know man.
So he's working for a church or something?
I think so.
We just kept trying to become a
priest or something like that.
He was always super religious.
Always.
Yeah.
I'm glad he's retired,
right guy.
He had a lot of great fights,
man.
A lot of great fights.
One of the great snake,
the great,
his Kao of Tyron Woodley for
the Strikeforce welterweight
champ is one of the
all time highlight reel k combat Kale.
Yeah.
Literally Combo elbows the best.
I love the elbows and opera cuts,
son.
He's so good.
In tough.
Yeah,
man.
For sure.
He uh,
he's a guy that kind of like was real
active and like real proficient before
anybody knew anything about MMA.
He started when he 17.
Joey Joey's,
he called me a couple of times.
Should I answer the
phone and call him back?
Listen,
sucker
made a watch that Derek till
Darrin tells over there
eating pop tarts away.
500 pounds.
He's talking about Mckinsey
turns ass last night again.
He's terrible about that job.
Would he take Atkins weight?
Think that's smells.
What do you think happened?
You think she's just eating
fuck time.
I don't know Joey.
I don't know what Percy
Miss Weight by seven pounds.
She's fucking smoking though,
right?
She's very attractive girl.
Joey's right now in the middle of bonding.
It's a can't answer that phone.
He'll answer.
Hmm.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm surprised.
Go to
that's not there.
He's calling me.
Oh,
there it is.
I call you back where you been dog.
What does the speaker
we're on?
We're on Jre la.
A fight companion live.
What's up
time to watch people kick each
other in the fucking head.
You're on the air.
You on speakerphone.
You're what?
Oh,
ah.
Ah.
This Friday in San Francisco.
One day this week on the show to discuss.
You'll call me.
What do you call that?
Fucking extra,
extra terrestrial fucking comic.
Whatever the fuck
Martian comedy.
What?
Right.
Smoking the weed.
Daddy smoked.
You know what I'm saying?
Next week I'm going to tell a new asshole
that came out last night to see uncle
Joey.
I was dropping fucking no jokes on him.
His Shit.
I'm ready to go dog cryotherapy right now.
Just listen to the dogs by pink Floyd
therapy.
Then I'm going to pop up fucking podcast
and I'm doing a few spots that I had to
let these motherfuckers know
who's running things and I said
Phil against Wonderboy and
my man against the other guy.
I'll watch it tonight on tape.
Joey,
what time?
What time are you tapings on June 4th,
seven and 9:00 PM in Las Vegas.
We're at,
where are the,
where are they filming at downtown,
I think someplace they got.
It's a small place.
Joe was made for us.
It's like a hundred seats
less than the original room.
Nice and tight.
Really?
It's like,
it's like Providence,
Rhode Island.
When was the last time
you went to province?
A couple years ago.
That comedy connection.
Fucking deadly.
It's deadly in that.
So is this is the same
type of layout to 50 to 40?
Are there tickets available?
Uh,
there's no tickets available.
I mean,
there's something for you.
You know what I'm saying?
Right.
If you,
if you show up in the helicopter,
I can't deny it.
Batmobile.
I'll go down
than what you'll know days.
You know what I'm saying?
You just walk in and take the fucking
mic and tell people what's time.
But it's beautiful,
but that's it.
There's nothing available.
I can't wait for people
to see that special.
Joey's going to be fucking nuts.
I'm working hard.
I've never worked this hard in my life.
I didn't know the meaning of this and so
I listen to you or the tapings and try
and shit and now I'm
just doing 28 minutes.
That's all week 28 28 28 Oo,
I got to get the big,
I got to get the beginning more jazzed
up because I got to make them watch so I
got to go out there like a fucking medial,
you understand me?
I gotta go out there and hold them
until like 14 minutes and let him,
I got the strategy.
I'm going to go out there and fucking
just go off for about 14 and then we go to
us different corners
and then they come on.
I pick my shots.
I just picked my fucking shots
like when fucking Eddie's guys,
what that dude and he fucking
the really good striker.
I got to pick my shots in the second round
and then the third round go out there
and just fucking flip point combinations
ending with leg kicks the tent down
than the until you can't take it no more.
You know what I'm saying?
That's the strategy
right there.
I'm breaking it down to three rounds.
Joe Rogan,
you did it last night.
Joey you did last night.
The Ice House.
He said,
I told Jay,
I told Rodney set him on fire man.
Yeah,
no,
no.
I broke it down to three rounds
and I'm cutting back and adding,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm cutting.
I'm looking at it like an MMA fighter.
So I'm training for a fight.
So the first 11 minutes you guys fucked
and I got to jump on your criminal shit.
Like old school retool it.
Yeah,
the whole fucking old school.
Old School veto the second round.
I'm just picking my shots like,
like uh,
you've guy,
I guess Edson Barboza you picked his shot.
He picked them apart.
He kicked him in the side.
You fucked up the of road.
He kicks up her body and then the third
round I come out like fucking that black
dude in the 70s that sport when they
gave him the bottle filled with cocaine,
milk,
go roping,
drop some knowledge on the fuckers.
Don't know.
Thick bottle.
That's right.
Same.
One thing that brought up for
the fight against out though.
Okay.
That's the same one that gave
fucking toddler gets out though.
Don't tell me I know the
characteristics of that fucking know.
Ah,
you pick your dealing with in the third
round we come out like fucking all my
Brian was that trainer's name.
Is that a manual?
Joe Rogan.
We're watching it right now.
Jamie.
Just put it on the legs
is Arguayo Alexis Aguayo,
Aaron Pryor,
Panama Lewis.
I had my one was getting the
bottle would be original shit.
It shouldn't over Django
was sending up talking shit.
Yeah,
he gave me tell him some coconut
water rainbow looking back
and then Aaron Pryor came out just
throwing bombs and fuck the Aguayo up.
That was a great fight,
man.
This is the way you gotta do it,
Old School boxing.
Aaron Pryor,
the bottle.
It's fights.
He's like,
they get called the bottle that I
said get on the bottle that I did.
They capture that on video.
It has a bottle
like give him the bottle that I
met up with smoke coming out of it.
I wonder what the fuck was in that thing.
Cocaine did.
Damn,
he's doing work.
Look at him,
you know,
get the other one.
The one that I'm mixed.
I look at it.
Okay.
There's no,
no,
not that one.
Give me the other one.
Yeah.
How fucking beautiful is that?
That's one bottle.
He's going to sniff and shit.
No,
that dragon was,
and that was the one he goes,
give me that one thing.
He got hurt before he fucked up.
Guayle had a nasty right hand man.
Okay.
And he was watery.
His shit wrong.
So this is not the main event,
is it?
Yeah.
This is the main event.
Can we are all right,
let's go right to,
to the fight,
Joe.
We,
we're about to watch wanting to boyfriend.
He's still,
we love you man.
I will see you this week,
brothers.
Thank you man.
See it.
But here's Darren till,
who's better than him?
He's the best.
His love that guy.
Oh,
then Joey saying till,
I'm like,
well right now.
Well,
it's kind of amazing that he's
even top 10 with one win over.
A big guy in Donald Cerrone
is really 155 pounder.
Yeah,
it's very,
it's,
it's insane that I'm picking
them to win the fight,
but I am not a fan of
how they do the ratings,
I think.
Do you think that's a Fox thing?
So is he as being in a stick with it?
I don't know.
Is it foxes decide decision that was,
that was one of Fox deals.
They want rankings because they didn't
think the public could understand.
You know,
who was who without the rankings to
arbitrary in to the two disagreed upon by
high level people,
it will not,
no matter how you do it,
you can never get it right.
So you might as well just
try it and just let it,
you know,
let it fly.
You've got to have rank.
This is the problem.
You just let it fly.
Is fighters going,
wait,
he's,
he's six,
but I'm five.
I'm not fighting six men.
I want to fight for it.
We didn't know what was right.
We didn't know what I want to do.
What is right,
what pride did.
Just make them fight.
If you,
if you,
they trying to fight.
I'll never ask you again.
They try.
This is exciting man.
I'm fucking pumped for this fight.
It,
they took long enough.
I feel like we've been around until we
got those old school tie tattoos on his
back.
The kind of tap in.
They do that with the fucking the tapper.
You ever seen house?
That's old school tappers temple tattoos.
Is that his girlfriend on his arm?
I think it's his older girlfriend.
Or is it is not at,
oh
now he probably got them in Brazil.
They prayer pregnant,
have the best tattoo artists.
But remember he was
young when he got that.
Did the tattoo.
Yeah.
It looks like Charlene,
you think there's a guy out there with a
tattoo of a chicken is like a one night
stand like one crazy horse.
That was the hottest chick ever.
It was probably a million guys.
Yeah,
with the one nights then.
Yeah.
She sucked.
Amena stick everything.
I mean
I'm putting her on my back.
Respect reach back girl.
His girlfriend is his girlfriend.
Here we go.
Okay.
So um,
that's a commitment right there,
right?
Mary heard you're into that one.
That's how scared dudes our marriage.
Look,
I'll tattoo on my arm for my kid.
Married
marriage is too prominent.
It's too dangerous.
So many people scared of that marriage,
buddy.
Here we go.
Goes Darren till the sun.
I crowd,
man.
It's too bad.
Liverpool last yesterday.
Otherwise this place be fucking even.
I'm more fire
this big moment for this kid.
Big Moment.
We're going to find out a lot of on hands,
man.
He's big,
but so it's one deployment.
Wonderboy is a tall fella.
He's an inch tall.
Wonder was not as media,
is he?
No,
he's not.
Wonder.
Boy's name is Wonderboy.
His is the gorilla.
Yeah,
but who named Wonderboy?
Wonderboy.
And who named the grill?
The gorilla.
See,
that's it.
That's what's important.
That's what's up.
Yeah.
I don't want to find that out.
What if you called yourself
a big people would be like,
get off to a terrible guy yourself.
Big Brown.
It's weird.
Well,
what's your name,
man?
Hell.
Toda.
Nado.
Where'd that come out with?
Well,
sitting around thinking about nicknames.
Fuck Outta here.
Dan Hardee gave him the
nickname of the gorilla.
Oh,
there you go.
That makes sense.
How long ago did you get to them?
Well,
this says he officially accepted it
as of January 20th so cheers man.
Real recent.
Both.
Fuck,
what was his name then?
Well,
I didn't know.
I didn't know Dan hard.
Is it gone?
I just refer to him as the gorilla and
then three days ago he wrote with it.
I thought this was his
name for a while now.
Well,
it's January.
We're into may,
so it's technically ma.
I mean after he beat what?
What?
How long does a man have to keep a
nickname before it's a legit name.
Fuck Bro.
It's on spoken rule.
Could decide kick.
I don't have a nickname.
You want me to notice?
I get it.
I'm a wing man.
No,
but
we,
we know as a martial arts to ruin us.
Like the sidekick.
No girl wants to fuck the side.
That's like Robbins.
If you know the real meaning
to the dentist at sound.
Right.
The dentist also zinc in
his dick sucked in the bar.
She's a dentist is such
an obscure a nickname.
I think he got to leave Josh neer alone.
That's his nickname.
That's so obscure one,
you know,
but then they call Eve Edwards a
dentist at one point in time because eve
Edwards because of Erin's iron,
right?
Yes,
yes.
He destroyed it.
Broke his whole best.
Right.
Like I'm sure,
and Riley was one of those tough,
tough journeyman.
Yeah,
right.
Tom,
he wouldn't,
Robby Lauer made his UFC debut against
Aaron Riley and just beat the brakes off
of them.
That's another super impressive
performance by half old dos Anjos right to
Robbie Lawler fight like holy shit.
It
was an amazing fighter.
Amazing.
He's like one of the best examples of
a guy was holding themselves back by
staying in a lower weight class.
He did get the belt though.
Yes he did,
but he couldn't take it anymore.
His body couldn't take it anymore.
He was so big.
I ran into him in between fights when he
was fighting 55 and he was 200 pounds.
It's just too much.
When they start to decline a little bit.
Cause the weight cut was fucking with him.
Then he went to 70 now he's at night,
man.
Here we go.
Wonderboy.
How tall is Dosantos?
He's short for us.
One 70 year,
right?
I think he's five nine shorter.
See if you can find that Jamie.
I think he might even be five eight.
Yeah,
that's,
that's kind of short fat
Kelvin's probably like five ten five nine
but Tyrons five nine
to write five nine no,
he's got five ten five 11 a way.
Woodley,
Woodley.
I think he's five.
Nine.
He's,
that's what's so impressive.
I think Woodley's five 1105 nine it
says no one's got a bigger butt donk,
donk than Woodley.
When he walks into LPS,
fuck it.
Thighs on.
That guy is an ass.
He generates so much force.
You know I'm five nine now.
I'm like
fuck yeah,
leg.
That's a medical shit.
They say fucking high to
say five nine motherfucker.
You know what I mean?
How was the back feeling?
It,
it's hard to tell because I haven't been
able to train because of my knee and my
shoulder.
So when I get back into
my knee's feeling better,
I'm on the bike 30 minutes a day.
So,
um,
so I decided,
I decided,
I decided to hold off on the
shoulder surgery and decided,
yeah,
I didn't want to do to you.
What can I do?
I've got to shit you got wrong in there.
The Labor,
um,
rotator cuff and,
but they're saying,
you know,
I finally,
I got a second opinion yesterday and um,
they told me,
man,
unless it's hurting really bad,
just hold off on it and it hold off on it.
Why?
It's just,
um,
I don't want to go into surgery again,
man.
Just again,
I just had knee surgery and
then shoulder surgery surgery.
I'm just trying to rehab it with,
I'm going to try to rehab it with,
uh,
you know,
like shoulder rehab exercises.
I'm going to go that route first.
And if that doesn't work
then I'll have surgery.
But I decided I'm not going to
have surgery on my shoulder.
They're doing some crazy
shit down in Panama.
Panama is $25,000 expensive.
And you know when Mel
Gibson was on your podcast,
it,
I don't know man,
I'd have to it.
Is there a possibility that he was like,
you know,
he has some financial interest
in the company or something?
I don't know.
It was hard to tell.
He really wanted to do it for doctor
reared and he's good friends with that.
Kyle,
did he help it?
So I want to believe all that Shit's real.
I want to.
But every time there's,
there's,
you hear about stem cells,
there's a new way and they do it different
and now they're taking stem cells
from here instead of there.
Figured that shit out further.
Let us know.
They're all good.
But they keep getting better at it.
But talk to Tj because Tj had
some raving things to say it,
but he's an actor after
the Mel Gibson podcast.
Oh really?
And after he was there before
and then he went again,
he went again recently.
He said,
it's why do we have to go again?
Go to the fights,
start we go,
Ooh,
I'm scared someone's gonna be some.
Yeah,
I hope that's real.
Man.
They just tap gloves
and hugged each other.
Holy Shit.
There's a lot of respect.
This is the shirts.
I know.
I've no idea what's going to happen.
Isn't really have no idea what's
going to have no one died.
No idea.
Literally no idea.
I'm kind of nervous.
Here we go.
Bam.
What a boy's gonna have to be smart.
A lot of footwear to south
paws and other big point.
Here we go.
Get the size of tils.
Fucking thighs.
Boy.
Their styles look at their styles.
Both real loose,
but more and more based with till he's
gonna Throw Frog Lake round kicks.
The thing about wonder boys,
he's all light on the toes.
His trigger is insane
leg kick right away by till.
Very interesting.
I'm so curious about this fight.
She that video to pull it out of him.
Sparring.
Just beating the shit out some day.
Yeah,
it was weird,
right?
Yeah.
Very strange.
I had heard that good,
but he knocked him out.
Yeah.
Hurting him too.
I wouldn't post that if I was him.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
he posted some of him getting hit too
after that because he said people are
calling him a bully that I don't like
because that means he's reading the
comments and the,
he's reacting to those comments,
which means people can fuck with this guy.
If you're a young fighter,
to me,
tough men to navigate through.
Well those comments,
you got to leave them alone because
there's so many you're dealing with,
uh,
you know,
a pool of thousands and thousands of
people and who knows who they are or what
their,
those Pete yet.
But also a lot of those people
aren't happy for your success.
Like Ms. Brown,
their life.
So they come of course,
especially a guy like Tim is on the rise,
you know,
or anyone in the spotlight tries
that switch kick off the front leg.
UFC might want to hire someone to
help these younger guys with that.
Well just give him a little psychological
counseling on how to handle it and get
a social media expert in their tils are
going to close the distance and land
that left hand over the top.
Wonderboy is not there though.
Yeah.
One voice footwork.
It's fricking ridiculous.
Well this is the perfect kind of style
ram to an aggressive guy coming forward.
This is what he's used to.
I have to imagine.
That's why I took the
fight to stylistically.
It was like,
yeah,
big guy.
Aggressive.
Let's do it right after the fight.
Yeah.
Even though remarried,
just be Mazda doll who he's see
wondered why he shouldn't be there.
Right.
He better get the fuck out of there.
Don't stay there.
Yeah,
he loves it but he was a little off
balance and he didn't recuperate.
Well Darren made a shift as he was going
to launch that leg kick and he put them
in a weird position
where he was off balance.
I mean there's some good adjustments
going on here at both guys trying to find
the right day.
Oh Shit.
God till likes the fire one.
Aleks that slide with the right hand
forward and then look off to the left.
Are you good?
Oh Shit.
One,
two damn quick one to Wonderboy
letting them know it's still there.
Boy hasn't had a finished.
It's still there.
It looks till it tells a little hesitant
now wait a little bit now be careful
like a cobra man.
Be careful.
Oh,
you're talking about dude who was
like 57 and o was a kickboxer.
Good.
Wonderful.
I agree.
As far as high level striking,
I can't remember the last time two
strikers are matched up this well no.
And this is five round son who I'll take.
Ooh.
Yeah.
Who knows what's going to
happen and that's fine.
This is interesting.
So,
so there's high level.
I was just trying to figure
it out with the left hand.
Popped him with the left hand
is caught him at the end of it.
Not a lot of power but reached him.
He's letting until know
that he's down there.
Yup.
Snap.
He's also switching legs.
Switches,
dances.
Now he's all sideways.
It's hard to find a trading
partner who's to emulate Wonderboy.
Man.
You don't really get a
real look at to buy it.
He's picking his shots,
but I think he's trying to
frustrate till so till jumps.
It makes a mistake.
Oh,
looked for it.
I don't think that landed though.
Huh?
No look cool though.
And I was onboard.
I yelled out.
You gotta get off the cage here.
You've got to get out.
Yeah.
I think for one of where
these first two rounds,
just try to frustrate till
what time is it in England right now
there's seven hours ahead or they eight
eight so it's fucking eight o'clock it's
really late Thursday at eight o'clock
eight 30 at night.
I see,
I see.
I think it's seven 30
it's eight hours.
That's it.
Trust me.
Yeah.
You probably know.
So it's 9:30 PM right now.
Eight 30 bro.
What time is it now?
1230 I looked at my watch can,
unless there's a couple of
different times zones in the UK.
I thought it was just one and I
have daylight savings time or so.
Nobody should have that shit dead.
Arizona does it right?
They do.
They like fine.
Fuck with it.
And that our sleep we lose.
Got Fuck Yourself.
We got a two year old.
Yeah,
but how about when you gain that hour all,
it's nice when you gain
it for like two days.
Not worth it,
bro.
It's not worth it.
Fuck my test in the morning.
It's dark in the afternoon.
It's not your boys too.
Yeah,
he's two now.
Mike six got a man.
He's all into Harry Potter and Shit now.
That's cool.
Damn,
we got it.
We go to universal studios.
How awkward if you haven't been,
you haven't been a universal studios.
You need to go universal studios.
Fucking brules now the
three d simulations.
Hell yeah.
High level that that Harry Potter ride.
Holy Father,
the new guards.
A galaxy.
It Disney's pretty sick.
Yeah,
I was straight up scared.
I was scared.
That transformer ride is amazing.
Also,
the Simpsons rides amazing
land is sick or rides ever.
You know what's the best ride ever?
All time.
Hands down.
Flights of passage.
Avatar ride in Disney world in Orlando.
I went to a simulation.
It's incredible,
dude.
It's incredible.
It's like virtual reality.
You go in,
you sit on this bike,
you're riding a dragon,
you saw Avatar,
right?
You're riding one of those
things through the fucking junk.
It is every is think of like,
have you ever done that?
That there's the thing at Disney
land called soaring over the world.
Will you,
it's amazing.
Giant screen and flying like
over India and over the Everest.
It's a made sure that's not Disney world.
They don't know it.
Just did it.
Just did it sister.
Yeah.
Disney world.
Disney land has soaring over the world.
Oh,
but oh,
here we go.
Round to fuck
around.
I remember,
Oh till get a little more aggressive.
Tagged him with that left hand.
And that castle that,
that Harry Potter Castle that they build.
Like what the fuck?
That's amazing.
It's incredible.
Tills getting way more amped up.
Oh Shit.
Ooh.
One mistake man.
I know.
I wonder,
boy.
Such a good counter fighter and all that.
So he lifts where I'd done the,
Ooh gotta get off the fucking fence.
That's all till once.
So that first round you got
to give it to one or right?
I mean it's super close,
but yeah.
Yeah.
Give it to Wonderboy.
Wonderboy,
not a whole lot going on most.
I mean,
he landed like maybe two shots,
one of the body than that one.
Two of,
remember this though.
They're in Liverpool,
the home kit.
He's the hometown kid and the judges look
at a octagon control so that it's not
necessarily could give to wonder Boone
that that frontline Darren until I don't
think landed anything,
but he's going forward
and the judges are morons,
so like,
oh,
going forward.
That works well.
Give it to till he did a good job.
Didn't t they always ask a
question after they say something.
He's amazing.
Isn't he
fantastic?
Righthand wasn't it
the slides about to get
loose in the third round.
I feel like what's getting loose?
Heredi a little bit.
It's just such a dangerous chess game.
I know.
And Wonderboy hands,
motherfucking down side.
He's always like that.
It's like that.
That's that karate style sign.
Ooh,
look for it till slid,
slid to the right.
Tilt.
Elbows are no joke either.
Now if he gets in close,
they're the one that he landed on.
Cowboy was God.
Who else has he beaten?
It's about it,
sir.
Yeah.
I'm really in to anybody else.
He hasn't really,
he hasn't really knocked you off
your socks before that cowboy fight.
He's at some decisions.
The knockout.
You stop somebody too early on.
He had one stop.
It's,
Oh shit.
Ooh.
Damn.
One of the board.
We left Wonderboy top a very smart man.
Yeah.
Well this is like,
again,
stylistically such a great fight because
this is the style that Wonderboy really
does.
Like he likes a guy that's Uber aggressive
and when it turned in terms of like
high level technique bolt,
these guys are really good.
Really,
really good.
Don't till till keeps her on that front.
Like so I kicked the front line.
Oh No,
we wanted the little short.
Yep.
Ooh.
Hixon.
Yeah.
He doesn't like no wonder boy.
He's going to have to adapt to that.
Yeah,
they both switch it up,
don't they?
Yup.
Oh,
Ooh.
Just missed that head kick son.
But miss financial is as good as a mile.
Tills got great distance control.
They both do.
Dante,
don't they?
Don't they?
That's Irish,
isn't it?
I don't know.
My accent suck.
We need a high natto in here.
I have some scouts for us.
Amazing Kid.
Definitely a different
accent to at the thick man.
Yeah.
Sunderland,
Liverpool thick as Liverpool
I think is Ozzy Osborne.
Oh,
Russian in man.
Why did boy loves to do that?
Like Swish slit splits.
Yeah,
but it's,
it's so,
so hard to figure out what the fuck he's
going to do because he switches stance
as well.
He does it sometimes and
then we'll throw a kick.
Yeah,
he's,
he's about to rush in again.
Tills just trying to figure
out and pin him down.
But man,
it's not there.
I wonder how this is this
one of boy's game plan.
Man Kimmy,
commit and make a mistake.
They,
she capitalized but tills doing a good
job of not giving them much space where
the cages,
this is not happening in the center
of the cage as much as it's Ha.
Ooh,
Wonderboy try that sweat and
chills going to feel any pressure.
Get a finish cause till is absolutely
controlling the center of the cage.
They under boy did not have a lot.
Well now they're in the center and you,
you know that wins
rounds for these judges.
Yeah.
Cause they don't understand fighting.
Okay.
That place is packed too,
man.
Oh,
I'm sure they say,
you know,
he's a superstar superstar.
It'd be the face of the of uh,
England man.
Big knockout here.
It'd be the fee cause Bisbing he is,
but he's retired.
Yeah.
Who else is coming up in England?
Uh,
we got,
uh,
Michael Van and page.
Right?
Sure.
Yeah,
but he's not,
he's not in this level.
Um,
well why don't they give
him high level fights?
He just had fought a Rickles.
Yeah.
Do you see what he did to him?
No.
Fucked him up.
I heard he exploded his
face and choked them out.
Yeah.
And that was like his first,
like they weren't feeding him,
you know,
like that was a tough fight.
Mike van page daily.
Next they say and,
and,
and Roy MacDonald.
Musashi.
Ooh,
those are two very good fights.
I really,
me,
I really like page daily cause
they don't like each other.
They fucking hate each other.
I liked that fight.
I'll watt shout out to all the
10 plan of schools in the UK.
We got like a eight now.
Damn crazy lung,
10 30 lung,
this neighborhood.
How many cranberry Redditch Darlington.
Uh,
Shit.
Am I missing one?
Oh,
glass gal.
That's Scotland.
Scotland.
How many got worldwide?
About a hundred.
That's amazing.
That's crazy.
Amazing Ooze.
And it keeps growing,
man.
It keeps growing.
He hit him with that
psychic and the niece,
he wonder boys leg.
Bucko see that in the replay?
He didn't like that.
He hit him with three straight.
One of them really made his knee buckle.
Ma'Am.
Those things fucking so here it is.
Michael Van and Paige highlights.
Boom.
We'll kick them.
Oh Shit.
Damn.
Oh,
he's so fast.
That's again karate.
He comes from that point
fighting background.
You know,
there's a great karate
match that I watched.
I mean,
I don't know how many times they fought,
but on,
um,
uh,
they fought point fighting
way back in the day.
Um,
Raymond Daniels and Michael Denham page
fought each other and point fighting.
Now Raymond Daniels is the glory champion
and Michael Van and page is coming up
in Beltour.
Very interesting.
Oh,
he's a belt or champion now.
Raymond Daniels,
right?
He left glory.
[inaudible] here we go.
Here we go.
Darren till super aggressive here.
Now,
I wonder if a Wonderboy,
his knee is okay
because those,
uh,
he still hasn't landed anything now
except for those sidekicks to the knee.
Here's the land.
Anything to the head.
Nothing.
Wonder boys knee seems fine.
He's moving fine tooth around so far.
No shot to the head.
Yeah.
Ooh,
kick to the body.
Well,
the whole thing with Wonderboy is just,
you make a mistake and he counters you
and so far till hasn't really made any
mistakes but wonder boys
found a few openings,
but there's never been like one big bum
rush where he'd left a gap and Wonderboy
could drop a ball on him.
Did I miss anything?
Nope.
Nothing.
But they did show the replay.
The knee buckling a Wonderboy.
It look pretty now.
Yeah.
From what?
From that sidekick.
Oh Wow.
From a side kick front.
Like psyche through me.
But he's moving fine.
It doesn't seem like
he's a limping at all.
And he threw some kicks
with that left leg.
So you would be nice at one one.
It's hard to tell.
It's hard.
Wonderboy was a little
more aggressive though.
Yeah.
I wouldn't be getting
knocked out cataract out.
Same thing with the Woodley five who
was like go be more graph like and get
fucking starched by Woodley
still.
You got to,
well this is his style man.
This is his style.
His style is move around.
But the thing is until is so high level
as well that it's hard for this style to
even find its home.
You know you have an aggressive,
which counter striker this is,
I don't know what people expect.
Really.
Machida.
Yeah.
How about that?
My cheat at front kick
to vittores fell Cheetah.
How fucking dare you know.
Ooh.
The man's sign up fighting went,
you know what?
Enjoy the retirement.
He goes crazy.
Right?
That was the one,
the worst knockouts effort
and it just walks off.
Fucking nasty.
Starts praying and you see the
photo of the foot on the face?
Yes.
Text book front kick balls.
The balls of the feet.
You think feature goes to ride.
Just juices with every
Brazilian drug ever.
Uh,
my,
my heart hope so too.
I pray for that at night.
I pray for Golden,
like Masters Division.
Yeah.
Just go off and want to see
veins in his teeth against,
it's crazy that he's still
fighting Jesus Christ.
Dude.
He was around in the early days.
Is the only guy from the
early days still fine.
Oh yeah.
Wonderboy caught them
with that right hand,
man.
You could say the same
thing for Dan Henderson,
but he's officially
retired and he's retired.
But Wonderboy,
I mean [inaudible] was around a UFC 12.
That's crazy.
Henderson was around 98 so it
wasn't much longer afterwards.
You know.
Crazy.
Really.
They fought,
right?
Dan Anderson.
[inaudible] K Odum both times.
Yup.
Oh,
oh,
we caught all right and see till
starting to get anxious here.
This one's gonna get in trouble,
man.
Ooh,
well he's looking for wonder.
Boy gets big.
Juicy his legs,
man.
I mean his hands are dangerous,
but his powers in those fucking legs.
Oh Shit.
He's found that head kick a few times.
It was a sick slip by till who?
Just till train with,
I don't know much about his
to come bone and Liverpool.
Uh,
his coaches calling,
I forget his last name.
It's crazy.
One or boy's dad cranes him,
right?
Yeah.
It'd be tough dynamic.
Ooh.
Damn.
Number one now.
Just touched them,
but he didn't touch him at the very end.
With that a round kick to the face,
you might be fine.
And an opening for that one to blitz
out till just tagged them with that job.
Have a hard time
believing in these judges.
I don't have it.
Three nothing.
Right,
right.
In Liverpool dock to gun control.
Well,
judges are two,
right?
Or the American judges and the
English judges are all morons though,
aren't they all around the world?
Unfortunately.
I love the fact that you could say
that you don't work for anybody.
I know.
Isn't it cool?
And you can,
oh no till got poked in the eye.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Mark gutters more worried about
an eye poked anybody that boy,
that doctor got in that room quick.
The doctor just jumped in.
God,
where did he come from?
And now he's out.
He's trying to get a
little too much TV time.
Oh yeah.
Oh definitely.
And Marina mean to poker.
Reno.
Oh,
they were booing him.
Yeah.
He's saying no,
no.
Boom.
Oh Shit.
Sometimes I poked really Rev.
A dude up or a Dick kick.
Oh,
my dad tells get wild here.
You know.
Don't get too comfortable.
Okay.
There you go.
On over the top.
Oh Shit.
Oh.
He's getting crazy here
dude.
That I poke.
Really poke.
I wish you would have poked nine in
the first round or the round here.
Now.
I was trying to get loose.
Now it's about to get fun.
That was three,
so we've got two more to go.
Thank God this is a five rounder,
right?
Pissed.
Yeah,
it feels so.
I talk so much shit on
that fight is three rounds.
It ended there.
Yeah,
man.
Yes.
That dude has a prominent forehead
cheek bone situation going on.
I think gang is kind.
Got a little bit of that.
A little bit of,
it's definitely got some
fucking ancient man and I'm a,
he does.
I don't look like him.
He definitely boom.
That right hand.
That was the nice the counter.
I'm here.
Yeah.
Boom,
boom.
Oh that got him.
It did.
Definitely.
He slipped with it.
Yeah.
He went with it.
But it caught him at
the end of it for sure.
Look what I done.
I'm like tired.
This is his style.
You know,
he's so efficient at doing that.
Oh,
both these guys can do this for 10 rounds.
Yeah.
Round Four.
Here we go.
God,
it's,
this is a fight.
That is a great argument for the five
round fight for high level folks.
Maybe we would feel so bad if we were
leaving here and then like who won?
Who cares what even happened?
Like what,
what are the stats on?
Oh Dude.
Unless trenches and kicks landed.
Yeah.
Unless you're super and
you'd be so wonderful.
It was a hard jab.
Right.
Their kid,
they tilt better.
Watch his p's and q's though.
You are too hard man.
Yup.
But
juice is worth the squeeze
if can get it knocked down.
Okay.
Oh Shit.
Damn.
This is getting hot.
Yeah.
Cause Yeah.
Daren tills never been five rounds as he,
no,
I don't think so.
He hasn't switched in the EOC.
This first made it well first times
because his main event against cowboy Jase
starts cowboy [inaudible].
Yeah,
that's his first main event.
Right.
And what about outside of the UFC?
How many fights he had?
What 17 or a 14 on crazy
speaks perfect Portuguese.
Oh,
does he?
I didn't know that.
Oh yeah man,
when he fucked Darren till a damn,
this kid's marketable.
When he fought in Brazil,
uh,
he spoke Portuguese to the crowd.
He lived there for like 10 years.
Right?
Yeah.
I watched one of his,
uh,
older fights when we stop this guy and he,
spoke Portuguese to the
crowd after the fire,
the guy up 10 fights were there.
Wow.
Yeah,
he went down there.
It just went to live down there.
They had to get out of Liverpool cause
I guess there's little talks it for him.
Well,
he got stabbed.
Yeah,
I guess that,
yeah,
you can see the stem mark.
Where is it a lower like on his,
uh,
it'd be on his rights.
He got to Dab in Brazil,
but right above his hip in England,
in Liverpool,
in his hometown.
And his coach,
his coach told him,
Hey,
you gotta get Outta here man.
If you want to continue to have their
knives and the UK and often off,
how many more people
got to get stuff that's,
you know,
the London mayor actually said that
if you get caught with a knife,
it'd be prosecuted to the
fullest extent of the law.
What about if I got to open boxes?
Princesses,
brother in law or brother got caught
with one when he went over there for the
royal wedding last week.
Oh,
that would be nice that he took one
because Trump's said that you should take
one with him and he was in a bar.
Oh,
he's crazy.
Is he crazy or brother's crazy?
She's a dime piece,
man.
Okay.
I'm assuming you to Deb.
Nothing.
No,
I didn't get the fuck down.
I'm watching it.
It's fine.
Your son,
one boy with a step in Jab.
Not a lot of action that's fighting.
Oh,
Wonderboy looking for that left
hand over the top because it land.
Nope.
Just kind of grazed him.
It's kind of hard to
tell his back was to us.
It's going to be a tough
fucking fight to judge,
man.
Tell us having a hard time hitting him,
that's for damn sure.
Beautiful Dark.
Under that,
we get this tail with a clinch.
What if he takes him down to,
we just stop the fight.
Interestingly,
the tills,
the one holding onto him here.
Oh elbow.
That clenches more ties.
Nasty.
Good elbow on the break there.
If you're one of my say
exactly what he wanted.
That lace kind of fucked up that lead leg.
Right leg.
Yup.
It does look a little bruised.
Oh Oo.
Good kick to the body.
Oh yeah.
You guys watched that show Cobra Kai?
No,
I haven't seen.
I've heard of course to be good.
Yeah.
No,
it's great.
That's a crazy well on Wonderboy.
His leg.
I really haven't noticed him
getting hit that much either.
It's on both legs to the,
obviously the right legs.
Worse with that left leg is pretty tender.
Roni too.
They'll ride lego.
It's really fucked us.
I don't really remember
him kicking him that heart.
It must have been when he was
standing in south park sideways,
you know,
and now he hasn't gone back then.
Athey really not mine.
Let's just round it.
Doesn't like it.
Oh my God.
He,
his footwork just stupid.
So Darren till can't
really get a read on them.
But again,
the judges are given that the till.
Yeah,
that nothing big has happened
where you go all that guide.
Definitely.
If someone likes someone
just knock someone down.
You've got the fight,
it shows Mike LP got the
good right hand to the body.
So such a high level chess game here,
which I did get.
I'm on the edge of my seat.
But if you're just a regular
fan like come on man.
I tell you what he's going to
get more shit is Wonderboy.
Cause there's one Woodley fights,
which 39 that's fault.
It's not his fault.
I'm just saying the public thing.
Shit,
I guess.
I don't know.
It's what it is.
It's this is the,
you mean you want to beat him?
You got to come after him
and he'd come after him.
You run into the woodchipper.
But the thing is he's not
winning when he does this,
but we didn't win against Woodley
when he did this for sure.
But he's lacking previously.
He's obviously got
number one for a reason.
He's number one in the world.
I'm happening there.
Cut that back.
Leg is fucked up man.
Yeah,
I'll do friendly voice
will [inaudible] yeah,
he's wobbling a little
on back to his corner.
That leg is fucked up man.
Maybe they just didn't loosen this fifth
round and just save it for the fifth
round.
Eddie.
I hope so.
Me Too.
Because again,
if it stopped right here,
I'd be bummed out.
I'm pretty lack luster.
I was really crushed to give it to till
I'm 100% know that every round of that
gift.
And then one like we don't
want to me too obviously.
And he gives one to one a boy.
I don't know.
This is up three to one till.
Yeah.
Real because of the judges.
Yes.
But knowledge is of what you think.
Right?
Uh,
even then it'd be tough.
You can maybe go to two,
but I,
I'd say tills winning this fight.
I don't know about that.
I think Wonderboy is winning.
Can I get some Goddamn copy?
Strike numbers.
Fox.
I know.
No wonder they left her ass.
Just kidding.
Can I get something?
How's your show going on showtime?
Enjoying it.
It's been good,
man.
It's been fun.
Nice to a lot of fun.
Did you know that guy that just died
without from the comedy division?
Yeah,
I did not.
Did you know,
everybody seems to think he's,
I might've met him,
but everybody seems to think
he's a really good guy.
Well that sucks,
man.
Yeah.
55 man.
I know.
Such a shame.
Crazy.
Burt love the Gar tea.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I burned up some real nice
to say about also the dice.
That's a bummer man.
Yeah.
Tills super aggressive here.
Coming off from me.
I'm sure he wants to get the finish.
Probably feels a little bit of pressure
and you should.
Okay.
They're same Darren.
Tills Corns,
very urgent.
Like he's losing the fight.
No.
Yeah.
I think he's losing.
You do.
Yeah.
I think if I would count up all the
different strikes strikes that landed.
Yeah.
I think a lot of us,
according to the UFC thing,
I don't know in terms
of strikes landed yet,
says 48 to 42 Goddamn,
that's tough to judge.
Yeah.
That's impossible.
One aggressor,
right in Liverpool.
I got to crazy.
Five rounds.
48 strikes landed.
That is just but not bananas.
Let a defense going on.
Yeah,
a lot of missing as well.
Movement.
Which tiles?
Right hand you think
would make for a great,
oh,
this a good right hand by Intel.
A Little Jab to the grill face.
Yeah.
Sidekick.
No one's really going balls
to the wall or they know
Darren to would go balls to the walls,
but wonderful.
It keeps moving.
It's hard.
Fucking writing keeps moving.
You don't,
you're blasting the face.
Yeah.
It's hard.
What did we come on,
man.
Just sit there.
What was that about?
He threw a Shitty,
we'll kick and then shook his
head and then they touch gloves.
It's fun.
Fucking weird.
Oh,
Ooh.
Switched up on them.
It's too are a little too
friendly for my liking.
He's looking to set up his
wheel kick with his left leg.
Someone throws something.
Anything.
The crowds like,
yeah,
that you have on their w w till,
but he doesn't.
Oh,
there.
Dairy landed a lefthand.
Why are they touching?
What do I wouldn't touch dab
cause got all the goddamn corner.
Oh is that about gorillas?
Don't act like that.
I don't understand this.
That does touch gloves.
Again,
too much respect.
I know there's not enough
killer instinct in this.
He's looking for that low fake and then
go with the high round kick off the
front leg.
He does that sometimes,
but he didn't do it.
And you just like to know how many
miles they've ran this goddamn fight.
You kind of give it to them
for sticking to their phone.
No one's getting out of
composure here to pros.
Pros.
No,
I get the style.
You don't,
you don't want to risk it.
But if you,
if you're not balls deep in a fighting,
you're not happy with this fight.
No,
I'm not thrilled with it.
This is one of the most
uneventful big events.
Who good jabs by till.
Oh Damn Guillotine.
Oh He,
I thought he,
Oh shit.
That's enough to win the fight.
100% that's why you need it.
Don't get drop time to go
a little bit of time to go,
damn.
How hard does that motherfucker hit?
And it didn't look like it.
Atlanta,
like behind the air.
We'd have to look at it in the replay,
but it look or you heard him?
I wonder.
Boy has got to move his ass now.
He lost the fight.
Well wonder boy,
he's in trouble now.
He might.
He's flat footed.
Yeah.
What are ways to be a little bit
trouble is what till lives where?
Okay.
Damn.
Wonderboy would have won to
till just out arrange for it to hurt.
This got interesting.
That's for sure.
Proud man.
Everyone's on their feet now,
but this is like wonder boy when
he fought Tyron Woodley to right.
Got Tagged,
got hurt and then people
rushing it dealt with,
look at this.
Wonderful.
I wouldn't fucking take down.
Awesome.
No Shit.
Ain't signed with Sony shoe in
for a take down or these stills?
Yeah.
Oh,
straight left
Wonderboy still dangerous.
Crazy.
Huh?
40 seconds.
Boys who tell just thinks
he has in the bag?
I don't think so.
I just think he doesn't want
to get tagged coming in.
He's a little tired too.
Mouth's open.
Hasn't been a high pace.
There's been a lot of foot work though,
so you might be a little,
well you got to rent and remember till
did have a real hard time cutting that
weight.
Oh and he's been going through a lot.
You're right.
They need some get downs in this.
You Ain't,
you ain't,
you ain't lying.
No standups.
Just get down.
Get down.
Yeah.
There's no way you have one a boy.
The flat after that.
It'd be hard pressed.
Especially in Liverpool man.
Until I want to boys
in a tough spot though.
I don't know why he's
that happy about that.
That was um,
I mean he landed a good shot.
I guess he was trying,
it wasn't like he wasn't trying.
Yeah,
he was [inaudible] drank till after
that lackluster performance cause he,
cause Wonderboy is number one.
You'll like him,
number one obviously I think
you put them in the top.
Waterboy is just a
nightmare for everybody.
He's a nightmare for everybody.
Yeah.
Just,
it's tough to look good against him.
Oh,
win over him is as a win.
You know,
he beat you back at number one.
Well,
he didn't even make the weight.
So that's,
that's where it gets tricky because
no one gives a fuck about that.
Right,
but you're saying that they fought here.
Here's that front leg side.
Kick that wobble his knee.
Good job.
Metro pcs.
A block in the vision.
God Damn it.
Metro pcs.
Why would they do that?
Why would they have that
right where you need to see?
I'll tell you right now,
if you're my friend,
you have metro pcs.
We are not friends anymore.
Knocked down,
knocked down.
Do you get angry with
just because of that?
Well,
no,
I get angry because the cricket
wireless cell phones now cricket.
Oh Shit.
Hard fucking left hand.
Boom.
Right bye.
That was legit.
The fight.
He clobbered them right
there behind the air.
Huh?
That was as legitimate gets.
Doesn't make sense.
That was the legit shot of the fire.
Like one legit shot.
That's why like if you have
49 other strikes at land,
do they even count?
I mean that,
that's a real,
strike that.
Do you ever use the word clobber when,
when you're calling fights,
I don't call fights.
Cooperate.
Claude was nine.
My addiction know bomber to
old school collaborating,
clobbered them.
Clobbering collapses.
The thing says that,
right?
Yeah.
If the thank you tastic
for clobbering time
guy.
I need to bring that up.
So what do we think here?
What do you think?
You think chill until all hundred
percent for one till around stone.
Close to switching.
I think til split.
Someone's going to give it
to Wonderboy to some rebel.
Some revenue wants to die in Liverpool.
I want to get going on Michelle.
They place up.
Will they set that place on fire?
If they do give to Wonderboy,
the report card and the paint,
you know there's some hooligans
then it's going to be a tough,
it's going to be a tough exit
strategy.
Is that a Dell,
Dell Bird?
Where the fuck her name is?
She the in Adelaide.
Birds fly her out there.
You never know.
She seen everywhere fucker.
Does she go everywhere?
Yeah,
she like gives lessons
on judging and stuff.
You don't think they put
her in there for a reason?
You know,
cause she don't give a fuck.
So you want to do it on purpose?
I think they w they want,
um,
controversy.
Do you want people to get
used to fucked up decisions?
What we're used to it that's,
yeah,
yeah.
I think they,
they want that because if they
ever needed to pull something out,
like something was like,
dude,
this motherfucker has to win.
You know?
People are like,
Oh,
it is Vegas.
Seattle boxing's crept his ship.
But with MMA,
I just think they don't know
what they're looking at.
They don't understand.
Correct.
They just don't know either way.
It's,
Oh,
here we go.
Here we go.
Jamie,
can you give us some volume
here?
We just split up or be
a killer strip club.
Dj 46 and 49
unanimous.
Oh,
Holy Shit.
Wow.
Well,
he didn't even need that knocked down.
That's a big fight for him.
What were some of those scores?
I can hear it.
(494) 074-0840 seven or
take 494649464847 well,
that's,
that's a big victory for him,
that's for sure.
You pointed Wonderboy,
these people they can get for you.
What does it feel like you're not fix?
You're on your way.
Hmm.
I think you said something bad.
I think you some potty language there.
What do you think?
I mean,
very strategic point.
Did you expect it to go the distance?
Did you think he was going to
be like the whole way through?
I played games and I don't speak.
It kicks.
I'm gonna get some flights up.
I on
the classified to
have such a specific way of talking.
I feel it's so much cooler when
they talk like this is a fighter.
Yeah.
It's pretty cool.
I thought
I'm going to show
up
in 14 so I was 13 I'm going to
hold this bike to figure out.
Not really.
Really.
I'd have to him.
Yeah.
Yes.
What does he saying?
What it,
but what are they saying?
Boy?
Fucking censorship.
Yeah.
Well let me,
let me hear the Bjorks neck.
Yeah.
Said everyone.
Anyone?
I don't care.
Yep.
People ask him.
Maybe you might visit the time.
She'll talk to me.
God Damn
with the censorship.
Yeah.
ESPN.
Please let these guys swear.
Please come on.
They're not going to let it.
No Way.
He's going to be worse and he owns ESPN.
That's true.
Good call.
Which is worse.
They might not even let me
do commentary over there.
You have you guys seen
solo hockey about that?
You out.
Disney took over star wars,
right?
Yeah.
Be Solo.
No,
dude,
I lasted literally six
minutes and I walked out.
Yes.
No,
six,
nine.
It's give it a shot.
No.
The reason,
the reason why I walked down,
I realize what it is about star
wars lovers in the chase scenes.
They,
they use the classic Star Wars.
Star wars movies.
Music.
Yeah.
Like that music is just so [inaudible].
Hannah Jones can't be corny.
I couldn't stand it,
man.
The fuck out and I was ready,
Dude.
I had fucking candy.
I was ready.
I had one of those of those
chicken baguettes with a barbecue.
Watermelon sauce.
Barbecue.
Watermelon sauce on you still walked.
As soon as I was done,
I killed it before then.
I was done with that before the movie
even started that the chicken watermelon
Barnsco by myself.
You went to see if it's
actually interesting move.
Wow.
At The arc light in Sherman oaks.
Really?
Yeah.
You showed up for yourself.
My uh,
my wife took my son to some,
uh,
birthday party thing and they were going
to be gone for a couple of hours and I
just said,
you know what I'm going to go to.
I like,
I like that the idea of going to movies,
it's just that they all suck.
But I like going,
I like,
I like buying some candy or solo though.
It doesn't matter.
I go by myself all the time.
I did,
I did not,
not so much since I had a kid,
but back in the day I would
go all the time by myself.
I think I've only been maybe three times,
not even in my life by myself.
I saw a student turbine only because I
want to be able to leave if I go with
someone else and I got a fucking state
cause nobody likes to talk to them.
And I like no,
most people don't like leaving.
Most people they get,
so I got to fucking sit there
for the whole stupid movie.
So have I like minutes.
I like the freedom to leave cause I won't,
I want as soon as I don't
give a shit about the movie,
I'm out or Deadpool two is amazing.
That was good.
I stayed for that.
I saw that by myself too.
That was good.
Yeah.
Deadpool tunes because
she moved by herself.
Know I really need that.
Yeah.
I've never,
I I just need to,
I just need the freedom to leave.
That's,
that's really what that's about.
Hmm.
Dude.
That welterweight division
is pure fire right now.
Yeah,
no kidding.
Right.
Pure fucking fire.
I think at all the young
guys out of Colby Covington,
Uzman and then,
uh,
Darren till,
till if I had to bet on
one of them being like the,
the world champion be till,
I think so,
yeah.
Out of all those,
the,
those three guys,
dangerous motherfucker,
that's for sure.
If you trade them with that guy.
I mean the thing that wonder boy did that
was so interesting is he's just never
there.
He's just never there.
And it,
it made it a hard fight
for to keep his composure
and fight five hard rounds and constantly
be chasing them and wonder boys never
there and wonder what tagged him a
couple times but til I was the one that
landed the big haymaker but you also
see till under control experience still
stuck.
This technique is me tough to beat man.
Now I'd like to see him against a
guy who has high level wrestling,
like a Colby come dinner Woodlea or uh,
even who you know,
been super high level wrestler.
I see that where it's not
ideal matchup for him,
see how he performs cause
cowboy and Wonderboy are there.
Striker.
So it's,
it's it's wheelhouse.
Yup.
Let me see your Rda.
Huseman or Colby?
Killington.
Yeah.
I would like to see him versus cope.
I think [inaudible] fine.
That's a good question.
Purple because the purple thing,
I'm pretty sure he's a purple.
He's been doing it for awhile.
Um,
but uh,
see,
I don't think you do Colby Rich Dad.
I don't think you could kill
off the young lions yet.
I think you let the young lions
go after the Robbie Lawler's,
the cowboys,
the RDAs do it that way.
They think that way or do they just try
and make the best fights that can do
UFC?
There's nobody saying,
oh just what do you like?
You know,
I think it's just whatever the fuck works.
Cause this fight doesn't make
too much sense for wonder boy.
Right.
But it's a fun fight for us to watch.
Yeah,
very fun.
Fight to watch,
man.
There's a clubbing punch or boom.
Yeah,
a lot of power.
he's got power and he's a big fella.
I mean if he,
if they wanted him to have to weigh
188 they know that he's probably well,
well north of that I'd probably come in
and well north of 200 c but missing the
weight,
we don't make a big enough deal of it.
I don't give a f I don't
really kill either.
But it is a problem and
it's a huge problem.
It's such an advantage.
But like with Mackenzie dern,
after she missed it,
I didn't care.
I'm like,
all right,
do your thing girl.
And she missed it by seven fucking pounds.
Man.
That's so big.
That means it doesn't drain her.
So when she goes to anybody,
that's a huge advantage.
Yeah.
She goes to fight.
She's not drained out huge.
That Mackenzie dern fight.
Holy Shit.
That was like some UFC two type shit.
She took that check down mountain her,
she soccer.
It was like that.
It was like a hoist versus uh,
that uh,
that Dutch kickboxer with the g pants,
which she got a crap.
But her striking was the impressive
thing cause she landed a bunch overhand
black.
She does.
She has big,
she's not afraid to throw
down Mackenzie fan man.
She's got giant balls.
Her ground game is so high.
She went scrape through that.
It looked like that chick never trained.
She looked,
she looked too thick though that fight.
She didn't like it.
I like sick.
But then there's like,
damn girl,
you need to,
we need a little pride here.
She said to the way she's dressed,
if she was in a miniskirt
with a halter top,
don't get a twist and I'm on board,
whatever.
She went,
I'm just saying that like the love
handles are spilling over the top and like
all right,
now it gets a little thick sometimes.
I like that.
I'm not mad at it,
but it just looks better.
It's all depends on how much
ask goes with the package.
You're right.
The front,
the front to back ratio.
It depends.
See,
this is why,
this is why we can't be
on ESPN or Fox fire me.
Good
fire me.
I dare you not even saying that.
Just make me just do the paper views.
I'm fine with that.
That's all you doing,
you know?
Oh well you,
no,
I do the previews to the prelims.
Ah,
well I want to have Latino cause well I
guess it would just the contract comes
over like does everyone
like the UFC tonight,
crew,
everyone's I've seen.
I was never working for Fox.
I didn't do the fire.
It was one of my,
one of these days,
but one of the stipulations
of my newer contract,
I said,
I don't want to do the Fox events anymore.
And that deals through when
you don't have to be done.
It's already done.
I mean it was a bit like this year.
I don't do any of the Fox events.
If you notice like when there
are big fights on [inaudible].
I know you don't do any of them.
I'm not even done.
The big ones.
Nope.
None of them zero paper if
he's still doing it right.
Do you want to do anymore?
Too much work?
Too much work did,
this seems is not a big deal because
they have the suit there for me,
but the,
my issue was a fox actually
paid me less money,
less money to do the fence on Fox,
but I was like,
you guys are never paying you.
Yeah,
I thought the UFC pagan.
No,
I get to Fox event.
It's a Fox event.
So,
um,
that,
but it was also,
I didn't like when I first
started doing it for them,
they got in my ear like the
very first events for Fox.
They were like telling me what to do.
They were like telling me
to take it down a notch,
don't be so amped up about that.
Yay.
And I was like,
what?
What are we doing here?
I go,
listen,
I do commentary.
This is what I do.
I've been doing it forever.
This is how I do it.
If you think you can change me,
then we're not going to work together.
I'm like,
we had what a real problem.
And that was a flop.
Seduction,
right Joe?
Yes.
It was a fox productions.
That's the junior dos
Santos Cain Velasquez upon.
Yeah.
I believe that was the first one.
But it's just,
I just didn't,
I didn't like it.
They want a sports guy.
Like,
look,
MMA is what it is.
It's,
it's fighting.
It is a very specific kind of sport
and I've been doing it the way I do it
forever.
If you don't like the way I do it,
that's fine.
Don't hire me,
but don't try to get me
to become some sports guy.
I'm not interested in that at all.
When I commentated for pride,
they told me,
I said,
Nice.
Too much.
No say Nice.
He was like,
no,
you couldn't even speak English.
I think.
Nice Shot,
Nice Jab.
To their credit,
they stopped.
They stopped doing it
after the first event.
When I voiced my displeasure,
I just let them know like
really clearly this isn't,
we're not going to doing this.
I'm not going to change how I do it to
make you do this if I'm helping you.
It's not even that.
It's just like if you
don't like the way I do it,
this is not an option for you to direct
me and tell me to do it the way you like
it because you think that that's better.
This is a personal choice by one or two.
Whoever the fuck the people were
that were producers or executives,
I don't agree with them and
I'm not doing it that way.
Like this is just how it,
it's like real simple.
Like if you bought a Ferrari and
it had a certain sound to it,
you're like,
man,
I don't like this sound.
Can you guys go back to the
factory and fix these mufflers?
They'd be like,
what
do you,
hi,
this is what a Ferrari is like.
This is you don't like it
then you like Ferrari's.
No,
no,
no.
I like it for a ride,
but I want it to sound like
a Corolla doesn't work.
They'd be like,
no,
you'd probably a bad analogy.
But the idea behind it you get,
I'm not,
this is what I do.
Like I get amped up if
some shit is going down,
these guys were throwing
blows and I'm screaming.
It's because I feel that with
some would call it passion.
Yeah,
it's bullets.
Legitimate Passion.
I'm not,
I'm not faking it,
but they didn't want that.
But they let it go after awhile,
but it's not like they fought
for me when I quit either.
How long has the Reebok deal for?
Uh,
three years.
I think three years.
Two to three years.
I wonder if it worked out for Reebok,
like his Reebok.
Reebok exploding now because of this.
Well,
Adidas zones,
Reebok to Adidas is killing it,
but I dunno,
free box exploding.
They,
they're the niche,
right?
The MMA,
the in with crossfit.
So they're in that world
until Reebok's defense.
You know,
they,
they made the offer,
they don't know.
They didn't know what the deal was.
They know they are screwing over fighters.
It's more of a UFC thing.
It was not Reebok Reebok,
it's like Whoa,
what the fuck.
It seemed like even the UFC wasn't
aware of how much fight is for actually
making off of sponsorships.
I mean you and I know that there was
some debate as to whether or not,
I mean they just,
they had a distorted perception of how
much some fighters were making and they
just think they killed,
I think they talked to maybe
the top 10 guys and we're like,
hey,
we're going pay you this.
We will take care of you in this way.
And then the rest of the
guys get on board and they,
you know,
but,
but again,
I get it man,
if I'm Dana,
I'm not making decisions based
off those 10 to 15 top guys.
I'll make my,
my,
my decisions that's going
to affect my bottom line.
And one was just what they did.
One judge and the pain fight gave every
round and Jason Knight One judge did
look at it like you,
like he was on his back and
he didn't get taken down,
but he was the one that was
aggressive on the ground.
I agree with that.
I don't think you just take it twice down
and have one thing you do and then be
in control.
It's just been educated.
Yeah,
I could get out of here soon.
Boy Sets wrap her up.
Uh,
Eddie Bravo.
Tell everybody you're a tinfoil hat
comedy at Cobb's Friday this Friday at
cobb's in San Francisco,
Saturday in Sacramento.
What are you doing on slot?
The punchline sacrament of that play.
And then I'm at the ice.
I'm at the Ice House on the
15th June 15th of the Ice House.
One show only.
And then I'm in Houston,
Houston Improv,
uh,
the 22nd,
23rd,
June 22nd,
23rd.
You can get your tickets@livenation.com.
[inaudible] dot com all right,
we love you guys.
Bye.
Awesome.